programming throwdown episode 88 image processing take it away patrick one of the things i've noticed has become a what do you hot new, well, it's not that new. A motif. Is the Netflixification of everything. Yep. That's my 20-letter word for the Netflix. Yeah, I remember when Steam first came out, I said, there is no way I'm going to buy a game on Steam where they could take it away from me.
Programming Throwdown 第88期：图像处理。Patrick，开始吧。我注意到一个已经成为——怎么说呢——热门新事物的东西，好吧，其实也不算太新。一个主题。那就是万物“Netflix化”。没错。这是我为Netflix造的20个字母的词。是的，我记得Steam刚出来的时候，我说过，我绝不可能在Steam上买游戏，因为他们随时可以把它收回去。
That seemed like an absolutely insane thing to do. And now, you know, it's just that's all like an absolutely insane thing to do um and now you know it's just that's all i use so what a huge change well now it seems like the world and i guess i have one thing in mind we'll talk about here in a second but the world has changed even more so one thing is owning digital assets uh and i'm not trying to get into blockchain discussion um but yeah but things like steam or kindle or you know but once you sort of buy it assuming the service stays up you can continue to use it i actually find myself reasonably okay with that like i understand the risks are probably not as well understood as we think they are but but i kind of understand it and things are much much more stable now
那听起来绝对是一件疯狂的事情。而现在，你知道，这简直就是我所使用的一切，所以这是一个巨大的变化。好吧，现在世界似乎变了，我想我心里有一件事，我们一会儿会谈到，但世界变化更大了。一件事是拥有数字资产，我不是想进入区块链的讨论，但确实，像Steam或Kindle之类的东西，一旦你买了它，假设服务还在，你就可以继续使用它。我其实觉得我对此还算能接受，虽然我知道这些风险可能不像我们想象的那样被充分理解，但我多少能理解，而且现在的情况要稳定得多了。
than uh than they were i mean when steam first came out, you know, I wasn't confident that it would last. But at this point, you know, I think we could feel safe that Steam will be there in our old age or whatever. Okay, well, you have more confidence than me. Really? Okay. Yeah, well, so the thing I want to talk about, though, is sort of the next step that I don't know, I've not adjusted adjusted to as much which is the sort of renting of everything so on netflix if i stop paying i lose everything um and now there's uh same thing i guess uh both sony and microsoft i think i've tried the xbox one what is it called i don't ever remember i'm not a big uh sort of video gamers probably not the best person to talk about it um but they have xbox gold i think well you get it you get games that you can rent yeah so the one where you pay is game pass or something isn't that what it's called oh okay
比以前稳定多了。我的意思是，当Steam刚出来的时候，你知道，我并不确信它能持续下去。但到了现在，你知道，我想我们可以感到安全，Steam在我们老了以后还会存在。好吧，你的信心比我足。真的吗？好吧。是的，所以我想谈的事情是下一步，我不知道，我还没有完全适应，那就是万物租赁。所以在Netflix上，如果我停止付费，我就失去了一切。现在也有同样的情况，我想索尼和微软都尝试过Xbox One，它叫什么来着？我记不住了，我不是个大游戏玩家，可能不是谈论这个的最佳人选，但他们有Xbox Gold，我想，你得到的是可以租赁的游戏。是的，那个你需要付费的叫Game Pass还是什么的，不叫这个名字吗？哦，好吧。
and you pay a flat monthly fee and then you're able to effectively just yeah like netflix rent or even says it's described as netflix for video games uh you can rent as many games as you want you just play them whatever game you want to play, it installs down. But as soon as you stop paying your monthly fee, you just lose all of those. And they can lose access to it, right? So like if their licensing deal goes away,
你支付固定的月费，然后你就能有效地，是的，就像Netflix租赁一样，甚至有人把它描述为“电子游戏的Netflix”。你可以租尽可能多的游戏，你想玩什么游戏就玩什么，它会下载下来。但一旦你停止支付月费，你就失去了所有这些。而且他们可能会失去访问权限，对吧？所以如果他们的授权协议到期了，
then they can no longer do it. And to me, I don't know. I guess it just depends on the kind of gamer you are. For some people, I'm sure this is a great deal. Like if you're a person who routinely spends more than, I don't remember i i guess it just depends on the kind of gamer you are for some people i'm sure this is a great deal like if you're a person who routinely spends more than let's i don't remember the exact price but say it's ten dollars a month if you routinely spend well in excess of 120 a year on video games that would not no longer be spent and instead be replaced with this kind of service probably makes a lot of sense but for me i only play video games which are typically many years old and are less than 20 and i don't buy them but maybe two or
那么他们就不能再提供这些游戏了。对我来说，我不知道。我想这取决于你是哪种玩家。对于某些人来说，我肯定这是一个划算的交易。如果你是一个经常花费超过——我不记得确切价格了，但假设是每月10美元——如果你经常每年在电子游戏上花费远超120美元，那么这些钱将不再被花费，而是被这种服务所取代，这可能很有意义。但对我来说，我只玩那些通常已经发布多年、价格低于20美元的游戏，而且我一年可能只买两三次，
three times a year then all of a sudden it's a i'm spending more but i'm getting a lot more um yep i think there's also like a psychological part of this as well which is um you know think about like a photo album right so it's like you take the photos you put it in the album and for that moment uh you know you really enjoy it and then maybe you take it back 20 years from now just to look at it right and and there are some games like that where you just go back and look at the achievements like maybe you just go back and play pac-man for fun or something and and you just you i i guess when you go in that rent mode you kind of go into it saying okay you know this isn't
那么突然之间，我花的钱更多了，但我得到的也更多了。是的，我想这其中也有心理层面的因素，那就是，想想相册，对吧？你拍了照片，放进相册里，在那一刻，你知道，你真的很享受它，然后也许20年后你再把它拿出来看，对吧？有些游戏就是这样，你会回去看看成就，也许你只是回去玩玩吃豆人找乐子，当你进入那种租赁模式时，你有点像是带着这种心态进去的：好吧，你知道这不是
permanent this achievement isn't permanent because eventually i'm going to stop this service and it's going to disappear but now with the future it seems that the current trend is about to be so i'm thinking about the google stadia announcement previously there had been uh both microsoft and sony have said they're going to do it as well there's been already existing services and pilots to try this uh the one i always think about it was the on live service which went belly up and then got bought by i think ultimately sony um for their technology but this is where instead of having a powerful video game console in your house, you have a cluster farm of powerful video game systems.
永久的，这个成就不是永久的，因为最终我会停止这项服务，它就会消失。但现在随着未来发展，目前的趋势似乎是这样。所以我正在考虑谷歌Stadia的发布，之前微软和索尼也都说过他们会这样做，已经有现有的服务和试点来尝试这个。我总是想到的是OnLive服务，它倒闭了，然后被索尼收购了，我想最终是为了他们的技术。但这就是那种不需要在家里放一台强大的游戏机，而是拥有一个强大的游戏系统集群农场。
And then all you're doing is streaming the graphics from those to your house and the controller input to the cloud. The so-called thin client, I guess, is the sort of paradigm. And there, owning things becomes even more tenuous because if I simply bought a game, there's recurring costs of running the servers in the cloud right and this becomes this kind of hard arrange a weird arrangement and so it almost uh if this
然后你所做的只是将图形从云端流式传输到你家，并将控制器输入传回云端。所谓的“瘦客户端”，我想，就是这种范式。在那里，拥有东西变得更加脆弱，因为如果我只是买了一个游戏，运行云端服务器有经常性的成本，这变成了一种奇怪的安排。所以它几乎……如果这
really is going to be the future you almost have to go to a purely rental model in my opinion because like you said if you want to just in 20 years decide to play your Pac-Man game, but Pac-Man needed this specialized hardware, which is only ever living in a server farm, what are you going to do? You need to pay a monthly recurring fee or whatever to have them keep running those servers and keep the lights on. And so that has to sort of be bundled in with the thing.
真的会成为未来，在我看来，你几乎必须转向纯租赁模式，因为就像你说的，如果你想在20年后决定玩你的吃豆人游戏，但吃豆人需要这种专门的硬件，而它只存在于服务器农场中，你该怎么办？你需要支付每月经常性费用或其他什么来让他们继续运行这些服务器并保持电力供应。所以这必须与那个东西捆绑在一起。
It's a, what is it? It's exciting, but a little trepidation as well because you're you're sort of subscribing to keep paying this fee and as soon as you stop yeah you don't really have anything you can't decide to save your budget this month and just play whatever you already have yep i think another one really good thing about this though is you know the the video the the economy of of being a video game developer has just been getting worse and worse and worse right um you know think about a video game costs the same price i mean i remember i bought mario 3 for nintendo my parents bought it i was i don't know eight years old and it was something like 60 bucks. And now a game costs 60 bucks.
这很令人兴奋，但也有一点忧虑，因为你是在订阅以保持支付这笔费用，一旦你停止，你就真的什么都没有了。你不能决定这个月节省预算，只玩你已经拥有的游戏。是的，我认为这还有另一个非常好的地方，那就是电子游戏开发者的经济状况一直在变得越来越糟，对吧？想想看，一个电子游戏的价格，我的意思是，我记得我买了任天堂的《马里奥3》，我父母给我买的，我当时大概8岁，价格大概是60美元。而现在一个游戏也要60美元。
And, you know, think about like zero percent inflation on the price of video games after, you know, 30 years or something. Right. So so, you know, the the I don't see how these companies can really stay in business like that. And I think moving to a recurring model, you know, might be able to sort of save the industry. I will say the technology of it seems really fascinating. Again, I'm not trying this myself, but everyone reports it works, in their opinion, pretty well. But the that I, you know, use my controller on Wi Fi, and it goes into the cloud, and then it makes decisions based on that input, and then sends the video back to to me like if that if you can really get that working smoothly that seems crazy like that sounds just insane like it sounds like physically impossible i mean i don't yeah i've not done sat down and
而且，想想看，30年后电子游戏价格的通货膨胀率为零。对吧。所以，我不明白这些公司怎么能那样维持经营。我认为转向经常性模式可能能够拯救这个行业。我得说，它的技术看起来真的很迷人。再说一次，我没有亲自尝试过，但每个人都报告说，在他们看来，它运行得相当好。但是，我用我的控制器连接Wi-Fi，它进入云端，然后根据输入做出决定，再把视频传回给我，如果真的能运行得那么顺畅，那看起来太疯狂了，听起来简直不可思议，听起来在物理上是不可能的。我的意思是，我没有坐下来
done the physics i'm not sure maybe for certain kinds of like high speed reaction video games it is not gonna work but i mean people see people have tried and said it looked pretty cool like i've not heard you know there always is going to be this risk of i guess uh unpredicted lag where all of a sudden everything just acts really bad um but i mean you experience that today in online games anyways yeah that is a good point but the difference is with the online games is um they do something called dead reckoning where you know you can even see this you can unplug the the your router and the game will still let you walk around as if as if you're you're connected um but just everyone else is
做过物理计算，我不确定，也许对于某些高速反应的电子游戏来说，它行不通。但人们尝试过并说看起来很酷。我没有听说过，你知道，总是会有这种不可预知的延迟风险，突然之间一切都变得很糟糕，但你在今天的在线游戏中也会经历这种情况。是的，这是一个很好的观点，但区别在于在线游戏，他们做了一些叫做“航位推算”的事情，你知道，你甚至可以看到这一点，你可以拔掉你的路由器，游戏仍然会让你走动，就好像你连接着一样，但只是其他人
frozen and so even in network games you might have a lot of lag it's still your response like the feedback you get for yourself is instant um and so now that's gone right i think uh you know the one thing that i think might make this work is if is if this the server is actually running like uh in your isp so if you know these companies have a deal with uh in our case it's comcast but you might be like on a votaphone or bright house or's comcast but you might be like on a vodafone or bright house or whatever it is but you know if all you have to do is reach your isp and back um you know then i think it can be really low latency even like maybe 10 milliseconds yeah i i mean i guess we'll see but uh there's more been more and more announcements everybody
冻结了。所以即使在网络游戏中你可能会有很大的延迟，但你的反馈仍然是即时的。而现在这消失了，对吧？我认为，我认为可能让这行得通的一点是，如果服务器实际上运行在你的ISP（互联网服务提供商）中。所以如果这些公司与我们的ISP（在我们的例子中是Comcast，但也可能是Vodafone或Bright House或其他什么）有协议，只要你只需要连接到你的ISP再返回，那么我认为延迟可以非常低，甚至可能只有10毫秒。是的，我想我们会看到的，但已经有越来越多的公告，每个人
is at least it sounds like all the major players are at least going to make a pass at doing this. We'll see what happens. I mean, all the TV manufacturers made a pass at making 3D TVs. And I was thinking about the other day, you know, I don't even know, can you buy a 3D TV anymore? Yeah, I remember when that was a big deal. You know, I think 3D TVs died relatively recently because I remember about a year ago that was still a thing and now
听起来至少所有主要参与者都打算尝试一下。我们看看会发生什么。我的意思是，所有的电视制造商都尝试过制造3D电视。我前几天还在想，我甚至不知道，你还能买到3D电视吗？是的，我记得那曾经是一件大事。你知道，我认为3D电视相对最近才消亡，因为我记得大约一年前那还是个东西，而现在
they're just completely gone i mean i know you can do 4k tvs like that's pretty standard now yeah that that's i mean that's just a straight upgrade so so that's so yeah so yeah so okay so now 3d tvs so but yeah i think 3d tvs is doa should we have a moment of silence yeah people oh have you tried getting on a tangent here but have you tried the um self-contained vr like the the oculus go yes or i think there's there's one from google yes i have tried the oculus go i got it as a christmas gift combined in with the rest of my family for for our father father. Uh, you know, the, the only thing I don't like about the go is it, um, it doesn't have, um, you know, translation, which, which is actually the most important thing. So it's like, you know, so just to explain what that means, like you could turn your head from side to side and, and, you know, it makes sense.
它们完全消失了。我的意思是，我知道你可以买4K电视，那现在很标准了。是的，那只是直接升级。所以，好吧，3D电视已经彻底没戏了。我们应该默哀片刻吗？是的，人们……你试过那种一体式VR吗？比如Oculus Go？是的，或者我想谷歌也有一个。是的，我试过Oculus Go，它是作为圣诞礼物，我和我的家人一起送给我父亲的。你知道，我唯一不喜欢Go的地方是，它没有……你知道，平移（位置追踪），这实际上是最重要的事情。所以，解释一下这意味着什么，你可以左右转头，这很有意义。
Like it, that feels natural, but if you take a step forward the system doesn't know you did that and so nothing will happen um but it's very close i mean if i don't know anything about about this kind of physics or how this would work but if they could make it so that um you know somehow it's a self-contained system maybe there's antennas sticking out or something but it would like uh track you your your movement as well. That would be really cool because you could you could, let's say, like map your house and then you could run around your house playing laser tag or something wild. Right. Well, that's the I think the HoloLens, the new HoloLens demos I've seen and the Magic Leap work like that where you you're still tethered. But yeah, there's not like if I recall, Craig, I don't think there's an external camera.
这感觉很自然，但如果你向前迈一步，系统不知道你做了那个动作，所以什么都不会发生。但它非常接近了。我的意思是，如果我对这种物理学或它是如何工作的了解不多，但如果他们能让它成为一个一体化系统，也许有天线伸出来什么的，但它也能追踪你的移动。那会非常酷，因为你可以，比如说，映射你的房子，然后你可以在房子里跑来跑去玩激光枪战之类的疯狂游戏。对吧。好吧，我想HoloLens，我见过的新HoloLens演示和Magic Leap就是那样工作的，你仍然被束缚着。但如果我没记错的话，Craig，我不认为有外部摄像头。
There's sort of cameras on the goggles. And your first step is to sort of look around the room so that you're the cameras can figure out sort of the pose and your position, you know, from looking at the room and identifying features. Yeah, that makes sense. I think that would be really, really fun. Maybe a little dangerous, like you fall over the couch or something, but it could be really fun.
护目镜上有摄像头。你的第一步是环顾房间，这样摄像头就能通过观察房间和识别特征来弄清楚姿势和你的位置。是的，这说得通。我认为那会非常非常有趣。也许有点危险，比如你会撞到沙发什么的，但它可能真的很有趣。
Well, those two are augmented reality. Well, I always mess up the names. There's augmented reality. And then what's the other one? Virtual reality. Mixed reality. Oh, oh, I see. Yes.
好吧，那两个是增强现实。好吧，我总是搞混名字。有增强现实。那另一个是什么？虚拟现实。混合现实。哦，我明白了。是的。
And then there's also virtual reality. Yeah, I haven't actually tried anything other than just pure virtual reality where, you know, you're on the moon or something. So wait, so bringing up the so your tangent back to the original topic. Is anyone talking? So moving the Oculus Go, it doesn't plug into your computer, which to me is a huge difference that one, it's lot cheaper um than a computer rig plus the vr goggles and the second thing like it doesn't plug into the computer but i guess that obviously limits the current graphics capabilities and stuff but yeah has anyone talked about like thin client vr or is the like any lag i imagine is just makes that kind of horrendous i don't know to be honest i mean well
还有虚拟现实。是的，我实际上除了纯虚拟现实之外什么都没试过，你知道，你在月球上什么的。等等，回到最初的话题。有人在谈论吗？所以移动Oculus Go，它不插在电脑上，对我来说这是一个巨大的区别，第一，它比电脑设备加VR护目镜便宜得多，第二，它不插在电脑上，但我猜这显然限制了当前的图形能力之类的，但有人谈论过“瘦客户端VR”吗？或者任何延迟，我想只会让那种体验变得糟糕透顶。老实说我不知道，我的意思是……
well so one thing the um one thing i've wondering is, you know, I wonder if the thin client is maybe too extreme, but there could be some middle ground there. Right. So, for example, something could maybe pre render parts of the image and get that down to you within, you know, 20, 30 milliseconds. All you have to do is just that one rotation. So basically you get all the geometry. The only thing the client has to do is handle the player movement in the very short term, and everything else could be done off-site. Interesting. So, yeah, it's like if you can just distort, roughly like distort the image for the couple meters of movement. Yeah, yeah. But, yeah, that's some really cool stuff coming down the pipe.
好吧，我一直在想的一件事是，我不知道瘦客户端是否太极端了，但可能存在某种中间地带。对吧。例如，某些东西可能预渲染图像的部分，并在20、30毫秒内传给你。你所要做的只是那一次旋转。所以基本上你得到了所有的几何图形。客户端唯一需要做的就是处理短期的玩家移动，其他一切都可以在异地完成。有趣。所以，是的，就像如果你能扭曲图像，大概扭曲几米的移动距离。是的，是的。但确实有一些非常酷的东西即将到来。
All right, time to news. So I think I got the first article. This is a kind of interactive game for explaining multi-threading issues. I played the first couple levels and I passed them. Woo! Nice. Not that hard um but a series of tutorials uh kind of going through um various issues with deadlocks and multi-threading problems and when i when i sort of saw the article come across like oh what how would you even and i i just expected if you've ever done these like capture the flag style
好了，新闻时间。我想我拿到了第一篇文章。这是一种用于解释多线程问题的交互式游戏。我玩了前几关，我通过了。呜呼！不错。没那么难，但这是一系列教程，通过各种死锁和多线程问题。当我看到这篇文章时，我想，你怎么能……我只是预料到，如果你曾经做过这些“夺旗”风格的
competitions or online things these puzzles that you, you're like download something, run something. I thought it was gonna be a fairly complicated setup, but I was pleasantly surprised. of two sets of code and a thread running on each and sort of, you know, how would you step the pieces of code in such a way to cause a problem to occur? And it is sort of trying to teach you a little bit about how to do it. And so you could have a critical section or a lock or a mutex and, you know, stepping the one, getting to it, getting to the other and understanding that some instructions actually are sort of multiple instructions in reality so if i say you know in c++ you might say counter plus plus but counter plus plus is is sort of actually two instructions
竞赛或在线事物，这些谜题，你需要下载一些东西，运行一些东西。我以为会是一个相当复杂的设置，但我感到惊喜。两组代码，每组运行一个线程，你知道，你会如何以某种方式步进代码片段来导致问题发生？它试图教你一点如何做到这一点。所以你可以有一个临界区、锁或互斥量，你知道，步进一个，到达它，到达另一个，并理解一些指令在现实中实际上是多个指令。所以如果我说，你知道在C++中你可能会说“counter++”，但“counter++”实际上是两个指令：
it's first you know get the value of the counter then add one to that value and then write it back um and so it's actually not a single atomic operation and so understanding that and expressing that this sort of goes through it and i thought wow actually i wish i would have had this before um and so you know thinking through that having these counters i i hopefully i you know i'm gonna actually go do some more of it afterwards because now that i actually sat down and tried it i kind of interested to see how far i can get and how hard it becomes because it seems a little bit and we've recommended those games before but the the video games like what is that most recent human resources was one um yeah and there's others where you're like doing sorts of programming tasks and they seem really easy at first but
首先，你知道，获取计数器的值，然后给该值加1，然后写回。所以它实际上不是一个单一的原子操作。理解这一点并表达出来，这确实贯穿了它，我想，哇，我真希望我之前就有这个。所以，思考这些计数器，我希望我……我实际上打算之后再去多做一些，因为既然我真的坐下来尝试了，我很有兴趣看看我能走多远，变得多难，因为它看起来有点……我们之前推荐过那些游戏，但电子游戏，比如最近的《人力资源机器》是一个，是的，还有其他的，你是在做某种编程任务，它们起初看起来真的很容易，但
then it's like oh man this is just like my day job only with a very weird programming language. Yeah, that's the only game where I've actually gotten all the achievements. Oh, really? Yeah, the last achievement is so hard. There's one where you have to build a sorter, but the rules are so tight. I think I had to unroll a for loop. Or even, it's worse than that. You have to unroll part of a for loop.
然后就像，哦天哪，这就像我的日常工作，只是用了一种非常奇怪的编程语言。是的，那是唯一一个我真正获得所有成就的游戏。哦，真的吗？是的，最后一个成就太难了。有一个你需要建立一个排序器，但规则太严格了。我想我不得不展开一个for循环。甚至，比那更糟。你必须展开for循环的一部分。
But it was a lot of fun. I highly recommend that game, Human Resource Manager. I feel like we talked about it once before. But if, yeah, always worth talking about it again. Yeah, definitely, we've mentioned it. Yeah, yeah, I'm not an achievement kind of guy. So I rarely, I don't think I've ever gotten that. Me too, yeah, it's the only time. Only time I've even paid attention to the achievements let alone got all of them but
但这很有趣。我强烈推荐那个游戏，《人力资源机器》。我觉得我们之前谈过一次。但如果，是的，总是值得再谈谈。是的，绝对，我们提到过。是的，我不是那种追求成就的人。所以我很少，我不认为我曾经得到过那个。我也是，是的，这是唯一一次。唯一一次我甚至关注成就，更不用说得到所有成就了，但是
it was a very very satisfying game but anyway so yeah check this out so uh i not said what it is this is uh it's called deadlock empire my guess is it's probably searchable by that term oh here i can try deadlock empire uh but it's on g. And yep, if you search Deadlock Empire, it'll show up. And then, of course, it'll be in the show notes. So the game is actually hosted on GitHub. Is this like JavaScript or something? Or you download an app or something? No, there's no download.
这是一个非常非常令人满意的游戏。但无论如何，看看这个。我还没说它是什么，它叫“死锁帝国”（Deadlock Empire），我猜它可能可以通过那个词搜索到。哦，我可以试试“Deadlock Empire”，但它在GitHub上。是的，如果你搜索“Deadlock Empire”，它就会出现。然后，当然，它会在节目笔记中。所以这个游戏实际上托管在GitHub上。这是JavaScript之类的吗？还是你下载一个应用程序什么的？不，没有下载。
It's just a web thing. Yeah, sorry, poor explanation. Yeah, that makes sense. When I expressed it to human resources, I definitely lost the context there. Yeah yeah so it's hosted on github it's a series of web pages i don't know the exact technological magic that they did to make that yeah that's that's uh yeah it's got a yeah probably some javascript engine or something all right my news is the godfathers of ai win turing awards this is pretty cool um a little bit of backstory here um so there was a time believe it or not where
它只是一个网页东西。是的，抱歉，解释得不好。是的，这说得通。当我向人力资源部门表达时，我肯定失去了上下文。是的，是的，所以它托管在GitHub上，它是一系列网页，我不知道他们用了什么确切的技术魔法来做到这一点。是的，它可能有一些JavaScript引擎之类的。好了，我的新闻是“AI教父赢得图灵奖”，这很酷。这里有一点背景故事。
um neural networks were really really shunned so neural networks actually went through uh we call the ai winter and there's actually two AI winters. But basically, people just kind of really hyped them up. And then they just failed to deliver twice. There are both times there were some some, you know, pretty serious limitations and, and it gets, you know, technical pretty quick. But basically, you know, people who, you know, had really good reasoning said, you know, we need to, but basically, you know, people who, you know, had really good reasoning said, you know, we need to be doing everything with neural nets. When you do image processing with neural nets, uh, you know, translation can be done with neural nets,
曾经有一段时间，信不信由你，神经网络真的非常被排斥。所以神经网络实际上经历了我们所说的“AI寒冬”，实际上有两个AI寒冬。但基本上，人们只是把它们炒作得太厉害了。然后它们两次都未能兑现。两次都有一些相当严重的局限性，而且技术性很快就变得很强。但基本上，你知道，那些有很好推理能力的人说，我们需要……但基本上，那些有很好推理能力的人说，我们需要用神经网络做所有事情。当你用神经网络做图像处理时，翻译可以用神经网络完成，
et cetera, et cetera. And I was actually one of those people. Um, I came into it much later, but my advisor, I guess I should say it was really one of those people, uh, saying everything you see with neural nets, they're so powerful. But, you know, after years and years of them not delivering, people just gave up, which is which is very natural. But not everyone gave up. And so, you know, Sammy Bengio, Jan LeCun, and I think Jeff Hinton are the three people, although there's others. They continue to advance the state-of-the-art neural nets, and they finally got that technology kind of off the ground. And part of that was a rebranding.
等等，等等。我实际上就是那些人之一。我进入得晚得多，但我的导师，我想我应该说，确实是那些人之一，说你看到的一切都用神经网络，它们太强大了。但是，你知道，在它们多年没有兑现承诺之后，人们就放弃了，这是非常自然的。但并不是每个人都放弃了。所以，你知道，Sammy Bengio、Yann LeCun，我想还有Jeff Hinton是三个人，尽管还有其他人。他们继续推进神经网络的最新技术，他们终于让那种技术起飞了。其中一部分是品牌重塑。
They switched it from saying neural nets to deep learning, which really just served as a way for people to try them again and not be bogged down with all of the baggage of all the failures of the past. But under the hood, there's also some technological advances and things like that. And so these folks won a Turing Award. For people who don't know, Turing Award is the most prestigious, you know, computer science award. It's basically the Nobel Prize of computer science.
他们把它从“神经网络”改成了“深度学习”，这实际上只是作为一种让人们再次尝试它们的方式，而不被过去所有失败的包袱所困扰。但在幕后，也有一些技术进步之类的东西。所以这些人赢得了图灵奖。对于不知道的人，图灵奖是最负盛名的计算机科学奖。它基本上是计算机科学的诺贝尔奖。
It's just very well deserved and uh you know honestly i never thought i would see uh i would see something like that um but uh i think it's amazing how far the technology has come it's really cool congratulations yeah totally um breaking news i just saw uh clicking through this article that valve just announced they're making their own vr headset called the valve oh man i'm not surprised because they have the steam vr already so it won't be breaking news by the time the episode comes out but it's breaking news right now release all the episodes people who are watching the show live uh so by the way if you're on our discord um i make a uh a little announcement
这真是当之无愧，老实说，我从没想过我会看到这样的事情。但我认为技术发展到这一步真是太神奇了，真的很酷。祝贺。是的，完全同意。突发新闻，我刚刚看到点击这篇文章，Valve刚刚宣布他们正在制造自己的VR头显，叫Valve……哦天哪，我不惊讶，因为他们已经有了Steam VR。所以当这一集播出时，它就不会是突发新闻了，但现在它是突发新闻。发布所有剧集，正在观看直播的人们。顺便说一句，如果你在我们的Discord上，我会在
before we go live um if you're on discord it sends a little push notification to your phone um obviously there's a bit of serendipity there um you might be asleep or you know you might not be available to just jump on discord at that moment but some people are and so if uh if you can watch the show live then you can find out about this right as it happens yeah uh so my next uh article news it's neither of those is a little device i came across uh reading i think some reddit threads called the odroid go and the odroid go okay i think we've talked about uh using a raspberry pi for doing emulators before um and actually came across it in that context that um you know hey there's this thing that looked vaguely like game boy um it's like a non-descript pocket console um oh yeah i see it
我们直播前做一个小公告。如果你在Discord上，它会给你的手机发送一个小推送通知。显然，这有点机缘巧合，你可能在睡觉，或者你可能无法在那一刻跳上Discord。但有些人可以，所以如果你能观看直播，那么你就能在事情发生时立即知道。是的，我的下一条新闻，都不是那些，是一个我偶然发现的小设备，读了一些Reddit帖子，叫Odroid Go。Odroid Go，好吧，我想我们之前谈过使用树莓派来做模拟器，实际上是在那个背景下偶然发现的，你知道，嘿，有个东西看起来有点像Game Boy，它是一个不起眼的掌上游戏机。哦，是的，我看到了
now uh and um you build it up from a kit i think it's like 40 or 50 us dollars it looked like there was some on ebay um like with all these things it's always sometimes a little bit hard to find out exactly how you would acquire them and it has odroid in it which i'm not exactly sure yeah i don't know what that is places and it has like a sort of android logo but i don't think it has anything to do with android um but what it does go does allow you to do is it is an emulator and i guess that's cool you know having played with that you know be legal but you know um emulators and the thing that i saw it for is that the chip on it i had come across before is this chip called the32, which is an ARM core 32-bit processor, but it's famous for being like a really cheap Wi-Fi device.
现在，你从套件中组装它，我想大概是40或50美元。eBay上看起来有一些。像所有这些东西一样，有时很难确切地知道你如何获得它们。它里面有“Odroid”，我不确定那是什么。它有一个类似Android的标志，但我认为它与Android无关。但它确实允许你做的是，它是一个模拟器，我想这很酷。你知道，玩那个，你知道，合法，但你知道，模拟器。我看到它的原因是它的芯片，我之前遇到过，这个芯片叫ESP32，它是一个ARM核心32位处理器，但它以作为一种非常便宜的Wi-Fi设备而闻名。
And I don't know if they have the Wi-Fi ability in here. I assume they do. But what they have for it is the Arduino IDE. So you're able to use the Arduino IDE and the Arduino libraries, which sort of act as kind of like a wrapper around a lot of pretty difficult things to do normally with embedded programming. And what I got sort of interested in was with this hardware and a screen and the thing that always takes so long figuring out how to sort of hook all that together with example code. This becomes what, if you've heard
我不知道他们这里是否有Wi-Fi功能。我假设他们有。但他们为它提供的是Arduino IDE。所以你可以使用Arduino IDE和Arduino库，它们有点像是一个包装器，包装了许多通常用嵌入式编程很难做的事情。我感兴趣的是，有了这个硬件和一个屏幕，总是需要花很长时间弄清楚如何用示例代码把所有东西连接起来。这变成了什么，如果你听过
Jason and I on many episodes in the past we've talked about how we got into programming and a lot of it involves and this is common with a lot of people i work with programming on the calculator programming in in q basic or some form of basic where there was like a pixel and making some form of graphical interactive you want to call it a game maybe it was a game maybe just a little sort of playing with with cool procedural graphics simulations yeah exactly um and here's a device that is you know but i don't think people can do that anymore because you can't from your from your phone really do that you hooking up your phone and getting the whole uh you know
Jason和我过去很多集节目，我们谈论过我们是如何进入编程的，很多涉及——这在很多与我一起工作的人中很常见——在计算器上编程，用QBasic或某种形式的Basic，那里有一个像素，制作某种图形交互，你想称之为游戏，也许它是一个游戏，也许只是玩弄酷的程序化图形模拟。是的，完全正确。这是一个设备，你知道，但我认为人们不能再那样做了，因为你不能从你的手机上真正做到这一点。你连接你的手机并获得整个Android开发环境或X实际上是一个非常大的任务，即使是做相对简单的事情。但在这里，我认为这个，如果我必须看一看，这似乎非常接近我开发计算器上的小交互式游戏的感觉，那里只有非常简单的低级方式来写出文本。
android development environment or x is actually a very sort of large task, like even to do relatively simple things. But here, I think this, if I had to look across, this seems pretty close to how I felt about developing sort of little interactive games on my calculator, where there's just really simple low-level ways of just writing out text.
而且你有，你知道，只是那种Game Boy风格的按钮。这里的好处是，看起来我还没有自己拥有一个。我正在考虑买一个来试试，但看起来有足够的例子。所以，例如，他们在Arduino中实现了《Flappy Bird》，这感觉像是你可以进去修改的东西，并且有足够的起点，就像你可以进去修改的东西，并且
And you have, you know, just the sort of Game Boy-style buttons. And the kind of good thing here, it looks like I don't have one myself yet. I'm thinking about getting one to try it out, but it looks like there's enough examples. So, for instance, they've implemented Flappy Bird in the Arduino stuff, and that feels like something you could go in and modify and sort of have enough starting like something you could go in and modify and sort of
有足够的起点，你可以在不担心大量的开销设置的情况下开始。如果你有一部手机，我想你也可以做到。我觉得对我来说，这几乎是那种事情之一。我不是艺术家，但你听到艺术家谈论它。有时创造力来自于某种限制，你没有的东西，你拥有的自由越多，它几乎就变得相当困难。这是一种专注，每一个限制都是某种类型的专注。是的，所以我感觉这是一个足够受限的环境，而像手机，你可能会被诱惑去尝试用多人游戏做一些疯狂的事情，而这就像在这里
have enough starting there where you could get going without worrying about, you know, the tons and tons of overhead setup. Um, if you have a cell phone, I think you can do that too. I feel for me, almost, this is one of those things. I'm not an artist, but you hear artists talk about it. Sometimes creativity comes from the sort of restrictions, what you don't have, the more freedom you have it almost becomes pretty difficult it's a focus every restriction is some type of focus yeah and so i i feel this is restrictive enough environment whereas like a phone you might be tempted to try to do something sort of insane with multiplayer gaming or and it's just like here
这就像，看，这很荒谬，你不会那样做。所以通过那样做，你限制了你能做的事情，我认为这将是一件非常非常酷的事情，因为我知道对我来说，回顾我是如何开始的，以及其他人，我认为拥有像这样的东西会是令人惊叹的。是的，完全同意。所以我查了一下，Odroid看起来像是树莓派的竞争对手。好吧，所以它基本上运行ARM处理器。看起来它支持Arduino和所有这些。但它比Arduino重得多。它有4GB内存。
it's like look this is ridiculous you're not going to do that uh and so by that you're limiting what you are able to do and i think it would be a pretty pretty cool thing because i know for me looking back at how i got started and other people i think having access to something like this would have been like amazing um yeah totally so i looked it up and the odroid is it looks like a competitor raspberry pi okay so it's basically it's running you ARM processor. It looks like it supports Arduino and all of that. But it's way heavier weight than Arduino. It's like 4 gigs of RAM.
它基本上是树莓派的规格。带有某种ARM，实际上树莓派，是的，是的，ARM而不是i3-86。此外，Odroid看起来有一个比树莓派好得多的GPU。但我的意思是，所以在那上面运行Linux并做一些事情，
It's basically the specs of a Raspberry Pi. with sort of like an ARM actually Raspberry, yeah, yeah, an ARM instead of i3-86. Also, the Odroid looks like it has a much better GPU than the Raspberry Pi. But yeah, I mean, so running Linux on it and doing something,
是的，也许，但我不认为，对我来说，这个Odroid Go，你知道，他们在这里展示了MicroPython的例子，你可以闪烁LED并将文本放到随附的屏幕上。这是一种方式，比如，是的，哦，在这里，有一个接入点服务器，你可以基本上访问该设备并从你的电脑切换设备上的LED。
yeah, maybe, but I don't think, to me, this Odroid Go one, you know, they're showing here examples in MicroPython where you can blink the LEDs and put text onto the screen that's included and bundled with it. Here's a way to, like, yeah, oh, here, here, have an access point server where you could basically go to the device and toggle an LED on the device from your computer.
我的意思是，这看起来是很酷的东西。是的，完全同意。所以是一个非常简单的入门方式。这太棒了。是的，它也不太贵。基本型号大约是，看起来是49美元。所以还不算太糟。你知道，我的意思是，最坏的情况，
I mean, this seems like pretty cool stuff. Yeah, totally. So pretty easy way to get started. That is awesome. Yeah, it's not too expensive either. The base model is about, it looks like $49. So it's not too bad. You know, I mean, worst case,
如果你在外面折腾，你把它烧坏了，你也不会损失成百上千美元。所以，好了，我的新闻是，这实际上让我大吃一惊。我觉得，你知道，我非常了解终端编程，我写过Eternal Terminal。所以我不知道，我不认为我知道一切。但我非常了解终端以及它们是如何工作的。而这个完全让我大吃一惊。所以有一种东西叫SIXEL，S-I-X-E-L。那些是你可以在终端中输入以绘制图像的ANSI代码。所以就像现在在你的终端上，你可以直接画一张猫的图片。
if you're tinkering out there, you fry it, you're not losing hundreds and hundreds of dollars. So all right, my news is, this actually blew my mind. And I feel like, you know, I know a lot about terminal programming, I wrote eternal terminal. So I don't, it's just, I don't think I know everything. But I know a lot about terminals and how they work. And this completely blew my mind. So there's something called SIXEL, S-I-X-E-L. And those are ANSI codes you can type in to draw images on the terminal. So like right now on your terminal, you could just draw a picture of a cat.
这让我大吃一惊。仅仅能够画一张猫的图片的想法。这让我大吃一惊。就像，我的意思是，仅仅是能够画一张图片的想法。我的意思是，它让我感到震惊，实际上，你知道，更多的控制台应用程序没有这样做。就像，为什么控制台应用程序不直接画图片，你知道，而不是做ASCII艺术，对吧？它非常繁琐，看起来有点奇怪。所以这可能是一部分原因。
That blew my mind. The idea of just being able to just draw a picture of a cat. That blew my mind. Like, I mean, just the idea of just being able to just draw a picture. I mean, like, it just shocks me, actually, that, you know, just more console apps don't do that. Like, why don't console apps just draw pictures, you know, instead of doing ASCII art, right? It is very cumbersome and kind of weird looking. So that's probably part of it.
我的意思是，说看起来奇怪，我是指API。但这个GitHub仓库非常酷。它是通过Sixel的GNU Plot。所以GNU Plot是一个用于生成图表的开源库。你可以绘制折线图、柱状图、饼图等等。现在你可以字面上直接运行这个命令，你就会在终端中得到一个柱状图。所以不是像一堆看起来像柱状图的管道，而是你得到了一张柱状图的图片，这真的很酷。所以我还没试过。我今晚可能会试一下。但如果它有效，那真是太神奇了。
I mean, by weird looking, I mean the API. But this GitHub repo is pretty cool. It's GNU plot through Sixel. So GNU plot is a open source library for generating plots. You could plot line graphs, bar graphs, pie charts, et cetera, et cetera. And now you can literally just run this command and you get a bar chart in your terminal. So not like a bunch of pipes that look like a bar chart, but you get a picture of a bar chart, which is really cool. So I haven't tried it yet. I'm going to probably try it tonight. But if it works, that's pretty amazing.
是的，不，我真的很想试试这个。是的，这难道不令人费解吗？就像，我们怎么会不知道这个？这就像，你只需要输入一堆奇怪的黑魔法字符。我敢肯定不是每个终端都支持它，但我敢打赌，你知道，大多数常见的终端都支持。因为，你知道，这项技术，终端支持，因为你知道这项技术，即使它听起来很陌生，我相信它已经存在很久了，而且，是的，你只需要输入
Yeah, no, I'm like wanting to try this. Yeah, isn't that mind-boggling? Like, how did we not know this? It's just like, you just have to type a bunch of weird Blackmagic characters. And I'm sure not every terminal supports it, but I would bet, you know, most of the common terminals do. Because, you know, this technology, terminals do um because you know this technology even this as foreign as it as it sounds i'm sure it's been around forever and uh yeah you just type
这些字符，按一定的顺序，你最终会得到像，你知道，终端上的一个紫色点。这很狂野，很酷。现在是“本期图书”时间。本期图书。我的本期图书是《影响力：说服的心理学》。所以有人实际上推荐了另一本关于说服的书，我刚刚读完。那本书还可以，但即使是那本书，作者也建议读这本书，而这本书似乎是理解说服的黄金标准。我猜这本会稍微，或者实际上深入得多，绝对比我读的那本书
these characters uh in a certain order and you end up with like you know a purple dot right on the terminal it's pretty wild cool it's time for book of the show. Book of the show. My book of the show is Influence, The Psychology of Persuasion. So someone recommended actually a different book about persuasion, which I just finished reading. That book was OK, but even that book, the author suggested getting this book and this book seems to be, seems to be like the gold standard of, of understanding persuasion. My guess is this one's going to be a little bit, or actually a lot more in depth is definitely
更长。所以，我想我还是直接推荐好的东西吧。为什么我要让其他人不得不读两本书呢？所以，我发现我读的第一本书真的非常非常迷人。它也有点奇怪。我的意思是，仅仅是说服力本身。所以，好吧，一件事是，听众，你们在家里不用担心。我一点也不擅长说服。
longer than the book I read. Um, so I figured I'd go straight to recommending the good thing. Why would I make everyone else have to read two books? So, um, I found the, the first book I read really, really fascinating. Um, it's also kind of weird. Um, I mean, just persuasion in general. So, well, one thing is, is, uh, uh, the listener, you folks at home don't have to worry. Uh, I'm not persuasive at all.
所以读这本书让我意识到我的说服技巧为零。我实际上并没有潜意识地控制任何事情。我相信每个人听到这个都很惊讶。但我意识到这是一种深刻的技能。而且想到这一点也很奇怪，好吧，也许这个人——我们以汽车推销员为例。所以这个人不想买车，也许他们不应该买车，但你可以和他们交谈并说服他们买车。现在他们有了一辆他们可能不需要的车。这有点奇怪。所以我认为这是你必须……我猜像任何事情一样，你必须使用你的道德准则并谨慎使用它。
So reading this book made me realize I have zero persuasion skills. I'm not actually subconsciously controlling anything. I'm sure everyone is surprised to hear that. But I realize it's a profound skill. And it's also kind of weird to think, okay, maybe this person let's use car salesman, for example. So like this person doesn't want to buy a car and maybe they shouldn't buy a car, but you could talk to them and convince them to buy a car. And now they have a car that maybe they didn't need. It's just kind of weird. So I think it's one of these things that you have to I guess like anything, you have anything, you have to use your code of ethics and use it sparingly.
读了这本书让我意识到我完全没有说服技巧。我实际上并没有在潜意识里控制任何事情。我相信大家听到这个都会很惊讶。但我意识到这是一种深奥的技能。而且想到这一点也挺奇怪的，比如，好吧，也许这个人——我们以汽车销售员为例——这个人本来不想买车，也许他们也不该买车，但你可以跟他们交谈并说服他们买车。现在他们有了一辆可能并不需要的车。这感觉有点奇怪。所以我认为这就像任何事情一样，你必须运用你的道德准则，并谨慎地使用它。
But it's kind of like a weapon that I didn't really realize that people had. But it talks about how to speak persuasively, how to convince people. And there's different scenarios. There's scenarios where somebody is completely against your position and how do you sort of start with some common ground and build that up. Um, there's scenarios where somebody, um, want some, someone basically wants something, but maybe not enough. So maybe the person wants to buy a car and you're a car salesman and you need to get them across the finish line. Um, a whole bunch of different scenarios. I mean, some of them didn't really apply to me.
但这就像是一种我没意识到人们拥有的武器。它谈论的是如何进行有说服力的演讲，如何说服他人。这里有不同的场景。有些场景是对方完全反对你的立场，你该如何从共同点开始并逐步建立共识。嗯，还有些场景是某人基本上想要某样东西，但可能意愿还不够强烈。比如那个人想买车，而你是汽车销售员，你需要推他们一把，让他们完成交易。嗯，还有很多不同的场景。我的意思是，其中一些对我来说并不适用。
There's like dating scenarios and just those days are over. Things like selling things that probably never will happen. But there are also, you know, how to give persuasive presentations. They also go over a variety of, there's a lot of historical anecdotes. So there was one thing in particular was, I guess, this idea that, you know, there's some stories that are kind of told and told and told, like Aesop's fables, you know, the Bible, or even just, I mean, you know, a lot of these, like, texts have a lot of the same stories in them right um and so there's there's some stories that either everyone knows or enough people know and it's it's kind of like
比如约会场景，那些日子已经过去了。还有像推销东西之类的，可能永远不会发生。但也有关于如何进行有说服力的演讲的内容。他们还涵盖了各种各样的话题，有很多历史轶事。其中有一点特别让我印象深刻，我想，这个观点是，你知道，有些故事是被反复讲述的，比如伊索寓言，你知道，圣经，或者仅仅是，我的意思是，你知道，很多这样的文本中都有很多相同的故事，对吧，嗯，所以有些故事要么是每个人都知道的，要么是足够多的人知道的，这有点像
the idea behind the story has then spread and so it's sort of like a subconscious thing there's people who don't even know they know. But if you kind of have these certain undertones when you speak and when you write, you can kind of tap into some of these some of these motifs and sort of like the analogy was, it's kind of like when you're riding a current or riding a wave. So you could you could, you know, you could just paddle by yourself, but or you could ride this wave of this sort of narrative that's been going for thousands of years, and you could use that momentum. I thought the whole thing was super interesting. Super shout out to, I don't know if I should mention his name, but a co-worker of mine who recommended that I read these books on persuasion.
故事背后的理念已经传播开来，所以这有点像是一种潜意识的东西，有些人甚至不知道自己知道。但如果你在说话和写作时带有某些特定的基调，你就可以利用其中的一些主题。这个类比是，这有点像你在顺流而下或乘风破浪。所以你可以，你知道，你可以自己划船，或者你可以乘着这股已经持续了数千年的叙事浪潮，利用那种动力。我觉得整个事情超级有趣。特别感谢，我不知道该不该提他的名字，但一位向我推荐这些说服力书籍的同事。
He had read them, and he thought they were really good. Well, that's why you ended up reading them because he had already read them and he persuaded me. Oh man, he persuaded me. Oh, I feel so cheated. I wonder if he got a cut or something. Did you click on a link he sent you in chat? This was in person.
他读过这些书，觉得它们非常好。嗯，这就是你最终读它们的原因，因为他已经读过了，而且他说服了我。天哪，他确实说服了我。哦，我觉得自己被骗了。我想知道他是不是拿了回扣什么的。你点击了他发给你的聊天链接了吗？这是当面说的。
But in person, he persuaded me and I'm pretty sure I bought that book either right while we were standing there or the next day That's how good he is That's how good this book is so so Jason has persuaded you to also go read this book Let him know that's right. So if I persuaded you you can go to audible. We'll plug it right now audible trial comm slash programming throwdown and And pick up a copy of this book for free. Well, same for my book.
但他是当面说服我的，我很确定我当时站在那儿或者第二天就买了那本书。他就是这么厉害，这本书就是这么好。所以，杰森也说服了你去读这本书。让他知道这一点。没错。所以如果我说服了你，你可以去 Audible。我们现在就推广一下，audible trial dot com slash programming throwdown，然后免费领取这本书。嗯，我的书也一样。
I will attempt to persuade you that if you would like to not learn about persuasion, but instead learn about a world where magic and guns mix. My book is The Promise of Blood by the book one of the powder mage trilogy which is which is a trilogy i confirmed because i've messed this up uh the trilogy is complete and out so also checked on that uh so i'm really trying to get my ducks in a row because i i've uh not always done so well and kind of knowing how many books are in the various series that I'm reading.
我会试着说服你，如果你不想学习说服技巧，而是想了解一个魔法与枪支并存的世界。我的书是《血之承诺》，这是《火药法师》三部曲的第一部，我确认过这是一个三部曲，因为我之前搞错过，嗯，这个三部曲已经完结并出版了，我也核实过了，所以我真的在努力把事情理顺，因为我之前在了解我正在读的各个系列有多少本书方面做得并不总是很好。
I mean, it's hard. You might not even know every time. And this book, I am listening to it. Oh, I did finish listening to it. It's 19 hours long. And like I said, this is a book where there's actually several kinds of magic. Several, I don't even call them them they're not called wizards there's several different sort of whole forms of magic and different people have access to kind of one
我的意思是，这很难。你可能每次都不知道。而这本书，我正在听。哦，我已经听完了。它有19个小时长。就像我说的，这是一本实际上有几种魔法的书。几种，我甚至不称它们为，它们不叫巫师，有几种不同的魔法形式，不同的人可以使用其中一种
of the forms of magic and they're able to do various things um and there's this book you know some books jump in and try to explain everything that's happened in the world and get into it this one sort of just jumps into the middle of things. And for a while, you're kind of just left trying to figure out what the various things they're talking about are. But I thought it was an interesting departure. I haven't read a book in a while. The other one I've recommended, the Lightbringer series, also has guns in it.
魔法形式，他们能够做各种各样的事情，嗯，这本书，你知道，有些书一上来就试图解释世界上发生的一切，深入其中，而这一本只是直接切入正题。有一段时间，你只是被留下来试图弄清楚他们谈论的各种事物是什么。但我认为这是一个有趣的尝试。我已经有一段时间没读过书了。我推荐的另一本书，《光使者》系列，里面也有枪。
But it's kind of an unusual thing. You don't often see sort of both magic and guns and so so is it is it is it just guns or is it is it is it more broad like there's there's there's you know is it like steampunk plus magic kind of yeah or is it just like total medieval fantasy no no no definitely kind of like i would say yeah like steampunk magic that's a good call yeah okay so there are some references to steam engines but i people don't go they're still riding around in carriages so it's not like medieval per se yeah right and this one is interesting because not only does it kind of
但这是一种不寻常的事情。你很少看到魔法和枪支并存，所以，它是，它是，它是只有枪，还是更广泛一些，比如有，你知道，它是像蒸汽朋克加魔法那种吗？是的，还是完全的中世纪奇幻？不，不，绝对是那种，我会说，是的，就像蒸汽朋克魔法，这个说法很好。是的，好的，所以有一些关于蒸汽机的引用，但人们不去，他们仍然乘坐马车，所以它本身并不是中世纪的。是的，没错，这一本很有趣，因为不仅
have just guns in it but actually gunpowder itself is uh used in sort of kind some some of the kinds of magic like it's a kind of magical substance. But as far as I hear it, they just... It reminds me of Full Metal Alchemist. Oh, I have not... Oh, maybe it is. Maybe it's like, maybe they just lifted that as an idea. I don't know. I don't know what Full Metal Alchemist is. I'm sure that
里面有枪，而且火药本身也被用在某种魔法中，就像它是一种魔法物质。但据我所知，他们只是……这让我想起了《钢之炼金术师》。哦，我没有……哦，也许是吧。也许是，也许他们只是借用了那个想法。我不知道。我不知道《钢之炼金术师》是什么。我相信
that trope has been around. But yeah, that's cool. But yeah, I thought it was pretty interesting. Again, I don't want to spoil so much of the plot. But it wasn't... I personally didn't find this an especially deep read or a particularly uh this sounds really dumb a realistic magic system like sometimes when no i mean one that like fits newtonian law in a sense like you shoot ice and and then ice could turn into water or something oh sure yeah that'd be a good example. Yeah, like, oh, I make magic ice, and therefore it doesn't melt.
那个桥段已经存在很久了。但是的，那很酷。但是的，我觉得它很有趣。再说一次，我不想剧透太多情节。但我个人并不觉得这是一本特别深刻的书，或者特别……这听起来真的很蠢，一个现实的魔法系统，就像有时，不，我的意思是那种符合牛顿定律的，比如你射出冰，然后冰可以变成水之类的。哦，当然，是的，那会是一个很好的例子。是的，就像，哦，我制造了魔法冰，所以它不会融化。
And it's like, oh, come on now. Yeah. But not referencing any Disney movies. Yeah, I guess, like you said, it kind of has what seems to be a little bit plausible. But yeah, I found this one to be good and interesting. But to me, some magic systems are explored in the sort of socio-economic impact that it would have like oh if you had this skill
然后就像，哦，拜托。是的。但不是指任何迪士尼电影。是的，我想，就像你说的，它似乎有一点合理性。但是的，我觉得这一本很好，很有趣。但对我来说，有些魔法系统是在社会经济影响方面进行探索的，比如，哦，如果你有这种技能
you know you would enter into this kind of trade or you know you would be desired because you'd be really good at these kinds of tasks so like in a world where there were magicians who could remove friction between two objects like you would never use oils or bearings if that magic was common because you would just have magicians decrease the friction of the thing you need um yeah i'm not that's not in this i'm just making up a imagine example it's like oh okay this is sort of a i would consider that kind of like a realistic or a you know kind of hard magic but where you're trying to kind of really think through the implications of everything, not just have like a good story where there's magic.
你知道，你会进入这种行业，或者，你知道，你会很受欢迎，因为你非常擅长这些任务。所以，在一个有魔法师可以消除两个物体之间摩擦的世界里，如果这种魔法很常见，你就永远不会使用油或轴承，因为你只会让魔法师减少你需要的东西的摩擦力。嗯，是的，我不是，那不在书里，我只是编造一个想象的例子。这就像，哦，好的，这是一种，我会认为这是一种现实的，或者你知道，一种硬魔法，但你是在试图真正思考所有事情的含义，而不仅仅是有一个好故事，里面有魔法。
Yeah, it's kind of like in, you know, the Final Fantasy video games, it is always interesting how, you know, everyone has access to a life spell, but then the major characters will die as part of the plot. And it's kind of like, you really have to suspend disbelief to absorb that. Oh, I never thought about that. Wow, you're right. Yeah, it's just like, why don't you just cast Life? They can die in battle, but then you could bring them back.
是的，这有点像在《最终幻想》电子游戏中，有趣的是，每个人都可以使用复活咒，但主要角色还是会作为情节的一部分死去。这有点像，你真的必须暂停怀疑才能接受这一点。哦，我从来没想过这个问题。哇，你是对的。是的，就像，为什么你不直接施放复活术？他们可以在战斗中死去，但你可以把他们带回来。
But then they could die outside of a battle, and you can't bring them back. Yeah, there was actually one Final Fantasy game. I think it was Final Fantasy III where somebody dies, and the person casts life and then life 2, life 3 and re-raise and none of them work and I thought okay well that's at least an homage to this. Cool, alright
但他们可以在战斗外死去，你就不能把他们带回来了。是的，实际上有一款《最终幻想》游戏。我想是《最终幻想3》，有人死了，然后那个人施放了复活术，然后是复活2，复活3和再起，但都没有用，我想，好吧，这至少是对这个问题的致敬。酷，好的
if we didn't persuade you to buy our books you can still help us out by joining our Patreon and being a patron you get a super fast RSS feed. The downloads are much better. And also we, you know, kind of take that money and we figure out ways to get more people to listen to the show, you know, which helps them out. I actually talked to there's a person who
如果我们没能说服你买我们的书，你仍然可以通过加入我们的 Patreon 并成为赞助人来帮助我们，你会得到一个超快的 RSS 源。下载效果好得多。而且我们也，你知道，把那些钱拿出来，想办法让更多的人收听这个节目，你知道，这会对他们有帮助。我实际上和一个人谈过，那个人
just happened to be in the Bay Area and they reached out to me and they said, hey, you know, did you want to meet up? I said, sure. I said, you know, so we ended up meeting up and I had a really great conversation. And it was it was actually just really touching that, you know, this person was not a CS major or anything like that. Completely different discipline, still in the sciences, but, um, you know, a totally different science. And, um, you know, they, they're listening, you know, they were kind of, um, what's the word they're dabbling in different fields or doing contract work and things like that. Um, but after they listened to our podcast, they realized that, that really what they want to do is, is do is programming. And so they kind of taught themselves.
正好在湾区，他们联系了我，说，嘿，你知道，你想见面吗？我说，当然。我说，你知道，所以我们最终见面了，我进行了一次非常棒的谈话。而且，这真的很感人，你知道，这个人不是计算机专业的，或者类似的东西。完全不同的学科，仍然在科学领域，但是，嗯，你知道，一门完全不同的科学。而且，嗯，你知道，他们，他们在听，你知道，他们有点，嗯，怎么说呢，他们在涉足不同的领域，或者做合同工作之类的。嗯，但在听了我们的播客后，他们意识到，他们真正想做的是，是做编程。所以他们算是自学的。
I don't know exactly. I should have asked what sort of, you know, lessons they took and things like that. But they taught themselves from scratch. And now they're working at a tech company. And they, you know, said a lot of it was because of our podcast, which is awesome. So we're going to try and reach as many people as possible. And that Patreon patronage helps us do that. So I appreciate it. All right.
我不太清楚。我应该问问他们上了什么样的课之类的。但他们是从零开始自学的。现在他们在一家科技公司工作。而且他们，你知道，说很大程度上是因为我们的播客，这太棒了。所以我们将尝试接触尽可能多的人。而 Patreon 的赞助帮助我们做到了这一点。所以我很感激。好的。
Well, moving on to tool of the show. Tool of the show. I have two tools of the show. Hey, that's cheating. These are pretty geeky um one is called pulp um and the other is called pi b and b so pulp is uh actually i don't know what the u is but it's python uh linear programming and pi b and b is python branch and bound and so i'll explain what these are it's they're pretty cool. So there's a lot of problems
好吧，进入节目工具环节。节目工具。我有两个节目工具。嘿，那是作弊。这些都很极客，嗯，一个叫 Pulp，另一个叫 Pi B and B。所以 Pulp 是，嗯，其实我不知道 U 代表什么，但它是 Python 线性规划，而 Pi B and B 是 Python 分支定界。所以我来解释一下这些是什么，它们很酷。所以有很多问题
where it's kind of like solving a maze, right? So you start at the beginning of the maze and you just kind of, there's not like a formula to solve a maze. You just have to kind of try it, right? So you have to just, and you can imagine even if you do this in one of those placemats
有点像解迷宫，对吧？所以你从迷宫的开头开始，你只是有点，没有那种解迷宫的公式。你只能试一试，对吧？所以你必须只是，你可以想象即使你在餐馆给你的那种餐垫上做这个
they give you at a restaurant or something something you're just kind of drawing the maze that you kind of get stuck you backtrack you get backtracked again it's like okay now i found my way out and there's just a lot of things in computer science that have that phenomena where you're kind of searching right so imagine you're doing, you know, a common one is the traveling salesman problem where you have to, you know, kind of visit different nodes and things like that. I won't get into too many details, but, you know, Sudoku.
或者类似的东西，你只是在画迷宫，你有点卡住了，你回溯，你又回溯了，就像，好的，现在我找到了出路。计算机科学中有很多现象都有这种特征，你是在搜索，对吧？所以想象一下你在做，你知道，一个常见的是旅行商问题，你必须，你知道，访问不同的节点之类的。我不会讲太多细节，但，你知道，数独。
Sudoku is one of these problems where you want to put in these numbers and at some point you get stuck. You know, you put in, let's say, two ones in the same row and it's like, that's not allowed. Or you're in a position where you can't solve it without putting two ones in the same row. And so you have to back up, erase some of your numbers, and start over, right? There's many things that fall into this category and usually they have one of two forms. They
数独就是这些问题之一，你想填入这些数字，在某个点上你卡住了。你知道，你填入，比方说，同一行有两个 1，就像，那是不允许的。或者你处于一种如果不填入两个 1 就无法解决它的位置。所以你必须后退，擦掉一些数字，然后重新开始，对吧？有很多事情属于这一类，通常它们有两种形式。它们
either have a linear form, which means you can represent it as a linear equation. So I'll give you an example. Let's say you could have horses and you could have chickens. And the horses you can sell them for $20. The chickens you can sell for $15. But there's other limitations. Maybe you can only have four horses, so on and so forth. So you could describe this as a set of linear equations. So you can say, you know, X is my horse, number of horses, Y is my number of chickens. And you can say, okay, X has to be less than four and X times 20 plus Y times 15 is how much money I'm going to make, right? And you can plug that into a linear solver and it will say, well, it will say infinite
要么是线性形式，这意味着你可以把它表示为一个线性方程。所以我给你举个例子。比方说你有马，你有鸡。马你可以以 20 美元的价格卖掉它们。鸡你可以以 15 美元的价格卖掉。但还有其他限制。也许你只能有四匹马，以此类推。所以你可以把这描述为一组线性方程。所以你可以说，你知道，X 是我的马，马的数量，Y 是我的鸡的数量。你可以说，好的，X 必须小于 4，X 乘以 20 加上 Y 乘以 15 是我将赚多少钱，对吧？你可以把它插入一个线性求解器，它会说，嗯，它会说无限
chickens. So you have to have the limit on the chickens. Let's say chickens less than 10 or something. And it would say, oh, well, you know, let's get as many horses as we can and then start filling in chickens. So you could also say the size of the animals and add those together, right? And so as long as you can keep everything sort of linear, like a set of just these linear equations,
只鸡。所以你必须限制鸡的数量。比方说鸡少于 10 只之类的。它会说，哦，好吧，你知道，让我们尽可能多地买马，然后开始填补鸡的数量。所以你也可以说动物的大小并将它们加在一起，对吧？所以只要你能保持一切都是线性的，就像一组这些线性方程，
then you can use Pulp very, very fast. And so you can represent so many different problems using linear programming. You can actually represent Sudoku using linear programming. So it involves some tricks, and it's cool to read about that. But then there are problems like navigating a maze where it just doesn't make sense. Like you can't really represent that using, you know, an equation. And so for that, you need branch and bound. And so what branch and bound does is it searches, but it does what's called a best first search. So the idea is at every point you
那么你就可以非常非常快地使用 Pulp。所以你可以使用线性规划表示这么多不同的问题。你实际上可以使用线性规划来表示数独。所以它涉及一些技巧，读到这些很有趣。但也有像导航迷宫这样的问题，它根本说不通。就像你不能真正使用，你知道，一个方程来表示它。所以对于那个，你需要分支定界。所以分支定界所做的是它进行搜索，但它执行的是所谓的最佳优先搜索。所以这个想法是在每一点你
say, okay, I don't know if this, you know, is going to take me to the goal or not. Like I don't have a guarantee of that, but I have a hunch. So maybe, you know, if there's two directions you could go and one direction is heading towards the exit and the other directions you're heading away from the exit, you might say, well, I'm going to head towards the exit because that just generally seems like a good thing to do, right? And that's branch and bound. And so the trick here is if you can get, you can get the linear programming solver and the branch of bound solver really, really, really fast, then you can kind of change the game a bit. Like you can just say, okay, I have this problem.
说，好的，我不知道这，你知道，是否会带我到达目标。就像我没有那种保证，但我有一种预感。所以也许，你知道，如果有两个方向你可以走，一个方向是通往出口，另一个方向是你正在远离出口，你可能会说，好吧，我要朝出口走，因为那看起来通常是一件好事，对吧？这就是分支定界。所以这里的诀窍是，如果你能得到，你可以得到线性规划求解器和分支定界求解器，非常非常快，那么你就可以稍微改变游戏规则。就像你可以说，好的，我有这个问题。
If I can represent it in this way, then I can take advantage of this solver this person spent so much time on. And that's basically how these work. So there's people who their whole job, their entire job is to figure out how to take some problem and turn it into a linear programming problem. So I was talking with a friend of mine
如果我能以这种方式表示它，那么我就可以利用这个人花了很多时间研究的求解器。这基本上就是它们的工作原理。所以有些人，他们的全部工作，他们的整个工作就是弄清楚如何把某个问题变成一个线性规划问题。所以我当时正在和我的一个朋友交谈
who works at Uber and they actually model the decision to match drivers to riders using a linear program. So I don't think they use Pulp exactly, but they've been able to take that problem and represent it using LP. So that's just one example. But these are really, really good technologies to learn. They're definitely on the more advanced side,
他在 Uber 工作，他们实际上使用线性规划来模拟将司机匹配给乘客的决定。所以我不认为他们完全使用 Pulp，但他们已经能够采用那个问题并使用 LP 来表示它。所以这只是一个例子。但这些是非常非常好的学习技术。它们绝对属于更高级的一面，
but these two libraries in particular are in python which makes them pretty accessible and they have good tutorials and things like that mine is not nearly so geeky i'm on theme i'm on theme though mine is uh an ios app i'm sure there are probably equivalent kinds of apps for android but this one on ios is really nice i've used this one personally and it's called halide and what this is is an alternative to the built-in um application the camera application on the iphones and oh okay the built-in uh camera application is really good i mean i like it the iphones takes good pictures i think almost all like i used to call like top of the line phones take really good pictures now um but there's a fair amount of i don't know so like guesswork that they do when you take a picture
但这两个库特别是在 Python 中，这使它们非常容易上手，而且它们有很好的教程之类的。我的没那么极客，但我是在主题上的。我的是一个 iOS 应用程序，我相信 Android 可能有类似类型的应用程序，但这个 iOS 上的非常好，我个人用过，它叫 Halide，这个是内置的，嗯，iPhone 上的相机应用程序的替代品，哦，好的，内置的，嗯，相机应用程序非常好，我的意思是，我喜欢它，iPhone 拍出的照片很好，我想几乎所有，就像我过去常说的，顶级手机现在拍出的照片都非常好，但它们在拍照时确实做了相当多的，我不知道，猜测
they may you have to make a lot of assumptions right because there's a lot of trade-offs and uh and taking the pictures and you don't want to bombard you want to whip out your phone and be taking the picture within a like second or two and if you had to configure 13 different parameters well that's not really good um yeah and so the default apps you know that that's sort of their prioritization 100 makes sense um but it turns out like the sensors have been getting better and better and so there's actually a lot of whatever you want to call latitude that you can do. And this highlight application is one you can bring up instead of the normal one where you are able to take raw images from the camera. So the camera API support giving this sort of full bit depth image, at least on iPhone.
它们可能，你必须做出很多假设，对吧？因为有很多权衡，而且拍照时你不想轰炸，你想掏出手机并在几秒钟内拍好照片，如果你必须配置 13 个不同的参数，那真的不太好，嗯，是的，所以默认应用程序，你知道，那是他们的优先级，100% 有道理，但事实证明，传感器越来越好，所以实际上有很多，无论你想怎么称呼它，你可以做的纬度。这个 Halide 应用程序是你可以调出来代替普通应用程序的，在那里你可以从相机拍摄原始图像。所以相机 API 支持提供这种全位深图像，至少在 iPhone 上是这样。
I'm sure something, again, exists on Android. But on iPhone, it allows you to take the full raw images. And when you take them and you look at the picture that's been taken using the Halide app, it looks kind of bland. It doesn't look like the colors don't really pop. It doesn't look that good. But it's okay. I'll spend a little bit talking about this because it's actually on topic um that when the image is when the image is taken that uh a normal jpeg is uh has what we call like a bit depth of eight bits which is there are at
我相信，同样，Android 上也存在类似的东西。但在 iPhone 上，它允许你拍摄完整的原始图像。当你拍摄它们并查看使用 Halide 应用程序拍摄的照片时，它看起来有点平淡。它看起来不像，颜色并没有真正跳出来。它看起来没那么好。但没关系。我会花一点时间谈谈这个，因为它实际上是切题的，当图像被拍摄时，嗯，一个普通的 JPEG 是，嗯，具有我们所说的 8 位位深，也就是在
each location in the image there's a red green and blue value and that can be 0 to 255 8 bits for each of the three but in reality the image sensors can sense more color than that they can often sense 10 bits which is four times more colors than that than 8 bits or sometimes even 12 bits which would be 16 times more than than the 8 bits and the problem though is the sort of common image formats people's displays. Those are all almost universally 8 bits and Or sometimes you hear called 24 bit color, but that's not 24 bits per color. It's 24 bits total 8 red 8 green 8 blue and then sometimes in computer graphics you'll hear 8 bits for alpha as well so to make a 32-bit number rgba um and so these rgb if you hear 24-bit color which is what most screens kind of do that's eight bits per color channel and so this one can do more
图像的每个位置都有一个红、绿、蓝值，它可以是 0 到 255，三个中的每一个 8 位，但实际上图像传感器可以感知的颜色比那更多，它们通常可以感知 10 位，也就是比 8 位多四倍的颜色，或者有时甚至是 12 位，也就是比 8 位多 16 倍。但问题是，常见的图像格式，人们的显示器。那些几乎普遍是 8 位的，或者有时你听到被称为 24 位颜色，但那不是每种颜色 24 位。它是总共 24 位，8 位红，8 位绿，8 位蓝，有时在计算机图形学中你也会听到 8 位用于 Alpha，所以组成一个 32 位数字 RGBA，所以这些 RGB，如果你听到 24 位颜色，也就是大多数屏幕所做的那样，那是每个颜色通道 8 位，所以这个可以做更多
but it can't display all those 12 bits at once so you have to if you effectively think about like a number line the number line is really big you either have to sort of normalize it down where you get what you want to call like quantization errors where two if you're only one bit apart in the original image you just collapse to the same number right so you collapse the entire range down to a smaller range but you can also do which is if you've ever seen this sort of high dynamic range imaging kind of stuff, you can also bring down various parts like, oh, they're really, really bright pixels, I want to bring those down. But I want to leave all the rest of the image the same. And so if you imagine taking a picture like of a forest and a sunset, the forest
但它不能一次显示所有那 12 位，所以你必须，如果你有效地考虑像一条数轴，数轴非常大，你要么必须以某种方式将其归一化，在那里你得到你想要称之为量化误差的东西，如果原始图像中只有一位之差，你只是坍缩到同一个数字，对吧？所以你把整个范围坍缩到一个更小的范围，但你也可以做的是，如果你见过这种高动态范围成像之类的东西，你也可以降低各个部分，比如，哦，它们是非常非常亮的像素，我想把那些降低。但我希望图像的其余部分保持不变。所以如果你想象拍一张像森林和日落的照片，森林
would probably be in like shadow, but the sunset is going to be very bright so what you could do is say oh i want to raise up the dark pixels and then move the whole image to just be more in the brighter range um and it allows you some more it makes some more flexibility there because you're preserving the whole bit depth and when you take your um when you use the default camera app it's making those decisions for you It's trying to do and they're really smart at it now. So they'll do things like actually take multiple images and stitch them together, use some machine learning that they've done to kind of like figure out what are the dark parts of the scene, the light parts, how best to combine them for an aesthetically pleasing
可能在阴影中，但日落会非常亮，所以你可以做的是说，哦，我想提高暗像素，然后把整个图像移动到更亮的范围内，嗯，它允许你更多，它使那里有更多的灵活性，因为你保留了整个位深，当你拍摄你的，嗯，当你使用默认相机应用程序时，它正在为你做这些决定。它正在尝试做，而且它们现在非常聪明。所以它们会做一些事情，比如实际上拍摄多张图像并将它们拼接在一起，使用它们已经完成的一些机器学习来弄清楚场景的暗部、亮部是什么，如何最好地结合它们以获得美观的
image and to make kind of beautiful colors. But it ends up being kind of your pictures look like everyone else who's taking a picture of the same scene because everyone's roughly doing the same thing instead if you're like oh i really care a lot about the clouds in this picture or i really care a lot about the textures of the trees and i don't care about the clouds you want to make your kind of own decision then having an app like this highlight one and this raw imagery allows you to if you ever kind of played with the sliders and editing the photos and you notice like, oh, if I make it too bright, it looks really bad.
图像并制作出美丽的颜色。但最终你的照片看起来就像其他拍摄同一场景的人一样，因为每个人都在做大致相同的事情，相反，如果你是，哦，我真的很关心这张照片里的云，或者我真的很关心树木的纹理，而我不关心云，你想做出你自己的决定，那么拥有像这样的 Halide 应用程序和这种原始图像允许你，如果你曾经玩过滑块和编辑照片，你会注意到，哦，如果我把它调得太亮，它看起来真的很糟糕。
I make it too dark. You get the graininess to the photo very quickly. This allows you to kind of have a little more room to the slider before you start getting that really nasty graininess pop in. But it's a more manual effort. But if you ever use, so like I'm not very good at it, but I do have a digital SLR camera, I kind of know how to shoot it in manual mode. I understand
我把它调得太暗。你会很快得到照片的颗粒感。这允许你稍微多一点空间给滑块，然后再开始出现那种非常讨厌的颗粒感。但这是一个更手动的努力。但如果你曾经使用过，所以就像我不擅长它，但我确实有一台数码单反相机，我知道如何以手动模式拍摄它。我理解
the complexities, I know how to edit it in sort of Lightroom on my computer. This brings back to me without that full setup, some amount of the pleasure that comes from that flow of being able to make very artistic or more realistic to kind of how i remember a scene pictures rather than just sort of the standard flat image because if you ever take a picture of a sunset on your camera you're like it's beautiful let me take a picture and then you look at later like oh this is like some boring yeah this doesn't look right right that's because your eye doesn't perceive it the same way but you can sort of bring that back um and you're trying to make it look like you remember it um and so i do you think that is there a lot of variance there but among people or do you think that i'm sure they're probably eventually the the camera will just will just do everything automatically i mean
复杂性，我知道如何在我的电脑上用 Lightroom 之类的软件编辑它。这带回给我，没有那种完整的设置，一些来自那种流程的乐趣，能够制作非常艺术的或更现实的，就像我记忆中的场景照片，而不是仅仅是那种标准的平淡图像，因为如果你曾经在相机上拍日落，你会觉得它很美，让我拍一张，然后你稍后看，哦，这就像一些无聊的，是的，这看起来不对，对吧？那是因为你的眼睛感知它的方式不同，但你可以以某种方式把它带回来，嗯，你正在试图让它看起来像你记忆中的样子，嗯，所以我，你认为那里有很多差异吗？但在人们之间，或者你认为，我肯定最终相机只会自动完成所有事情，我的意思是
i think it's hard from the camera's perspective because without them asking you, which is, so to be fair, this application is a little harder to use because you can do things like I want to set where my focus is versus if you bring the camera out and just take a picture, it's going to try to get as much of the scene in focus as possible because it doesn't know any better. It doesn't know what you're trying to take a picture of that bear in the distance, the person in the front, the clouds of a beautiful sunset. Like it doesn't know what you're trying to take a picture of that bear in the distance, the person in the front, the clouds of a beautiful sunset like it doesn't know. So that's why you'll see things like they'll now put boxes around people's face under the assumption that if a person's in your image and close, you're probably wanting them in focus. Yeah, that makes sense. And so you'll make they'll make all these hacks.
我认为从相机的角度来看很难，因为在不询问你的情况下，这是，所以公平地说，这个应用程序有点难用，因为你可以做一些事情，比如我想设置我的焦点在哪里，而不是如果你拿出相机直接拍照，它会尝试让场景中尽可能多的部分对焦，因为它不知道更好。它不知道你试图拍什么，远处的熊，前面的人，美丽日落的云。就像它不知道你试图拍什么，远处的熊，前面的人，美丽日落的云，就像它不知道。所以这就是为什么你会看到一些东西，比如它们现在会在人的脸周围放上框，假设如果一个人在你的图像中并且很近，你可能希望他们对焦。是的，这有道理。所以你会做，它们会做所有这些黑客手段。
And so I don't think they'll ever converge because it requires way too much iterative back and forth process, right? But this highlight app, it sort of re-exposes a lot of those knobs to you if you want to fiddle with them. So it's a much slower picture-taking experience. But I also sometimes shoot like old-school film. And that's an even much slower process with a very long feedback cycle before you sort of can develop the images and see what looks like you literally have a dark room and you you do
所以我认为它们永远不会收敛，因为它需要太多的迭代往复过程，对吧？但这个 Halide 应用程序，它确实为你重新暴露了很多那些旋钮，如果你想摆弄它们的话。所以这是一个慢得多的拍照体验。但我有时也拍摄像老派胶片那样的东西。那是一个更慢的过程，有一个非常长的反馈周期，在你能够冲洗图像并看到它看起来像什么之前，你实际上有一个暗房，你，你做
yeah yeah yeah wow that's amazing yeah i never did it growing up i just like it part to me it's just the chemistry of it is really cool uh i guess i'll have to show this one point yeah i actually did one step further where i did um like silver chloride raw chemicals to make my own sort of uh paper that was photosensitive and like exposed into yeah yeah just because i was like i want to know how this works that is unbelievable but i'm by no means good at it or sort of consider myself an artist but no but it's amazing it's sort of fun do that it's fun to me like i don't know yeah yeah i mean you just built something uh that everyone else is just dependent on yeah so i like know how
是的，是的，哇，那太神奇了，是的，我成长过程中从来没做过，我只是喜欢它，对我来说，它的化学反应真的很酷，嗯，我想我得展示这一点，是的，我实际上更进一步，我做了，嗯，像氯化银原始化学品来制作我自己的那种感光纸，并像暴露在，是的，是的，只是因为我当时想，我想知道这是怎么运作的，那真是令人难以置信，但我绝不擅长它，或者认为自己是一位艺术家，但不，但这很神奇，这很有趣，做那个，这对我来说很有趣，就像，我不知道，是的，是的，我的意思是，你刚刚构建了一些每个人都依赖的东西，是的，所以我喜欢知道如何
to make pictures the way they did like a hundred years ago for you know if the whole world has armageddon or whatever happens and everything goes yeah away and like if we go into nuclear winter i'm going to your house rebuild the world from scratch i guess i'll bring the photography equipment it'll be great yeah i'll bring the dog food you bring the photography uh photography equipment will be all set so um but yeah anyway so how light how light is the name of the app uh check it out you you would want to pair it with you know some ability to edit these files it's really good at taking them um but you need something which i can't i can only share one tool to show unlike jason who cheats um there are many but you know you also want one that does good editing yep that makes sense like but you wouldn't edit on the phone would you uh i do yeah oh wow yeah i mean you could export onto computer but look that to me is a different workflow if i'm
像一百年前那样制作照片，为了，你知道，如果整个世界发生了世界末日或者发生了什么，一切都消失了，就像如果我们进入核冬天，我会去你家，从零开始重建世界，我想我会带上摄影设备，那会很棒，是的，我会带上狗粮，你带上摄影，摄影设备，一切都会准备好，所以，嗯，但是的，无论如何，Halide，Halide 是应用程序的名字，去看看吧，你会想把它与，你知道，编辑这些文件的某种能力配对，它在拍摄方面真的很棒，但你需要一些东西，我只能分享一个节目工具，不像杰森那样作弊，有很多，但你知道，你也想要一个能进行良好编辑的，是的，这有道理，就像，但你不会在手机上编辑，会吗？嗯，我做，是的，哦，哇，是的，我的意思是，你可以导出到电脑上，但看，对我来说，那是不同的工作流程，如果我
on my computer i probably might as well just have taken it with the SLR. Yeah, that's a good point. Because the image chip is so much better. Okay, let's on to image processing. Processing. I could get started here. So, you know, I think one thing a lot of people don't realize is just physically what's kind of happening, you know, when you take an image, right? So, you know, I mean, everyone knows about, you know, I'm sure everyone knows about photons. You have the sun, it's a big ball of light. It's sending out tons of photon energy. Those photons are bouncing, you know,
在我的电脑上，我可能还不如直接用单反相机拍。是的，那是一个很好的观点。因为图像芯片好得多。好的，让我们进入图像处理。处理。我可以从这里开始。所以，你知道，我认为很多人没有意识到的是，当你拍摄图像时，物理上发生了什么，对吧？所以，你知道，我的意思是，每个人都知道，你知道，我相信每个人都知道光子。你有太阳，它是一个巨大的光球。它正在发出大量的光子能量。那些光子正在反弹，你知道，
all over the place. You can have, you know, light bulbs doing the same thing. And some of these photons bounce and hit you in the eyeball. And so what happens is you have these photoreceptors that, let's say, integrate or accumulate these photons. And so if more of the photons are hitting these receptors at a faster rate, then they are just more excited, right? And so that ends up turning into some electrical charge which then your brain kind of post processes and turns into an image right so a camera doesn't actually work that differently the way the the camera works is photons are also coming in and hitting the camera um uh photoreceptors and then there's these uh kind of like wells think of it as like little u's
到处都是。你可以有，你知道，灯泡做同样的事情。其中一些光子反弹并击中你的眼球。所以发生的事情是你有这些光感受器，比方说，整合或积累这些光子。所以如果更多的光子以更快的速度击中这些感受器，那么它们就越兴奋，对吧？所以这最终变成了某种电荷，然后你的大脑进行后处理并将其变成图像，对吧？所以相机的工作原理其实并没有什么不同，相机的工作原理是光子也进入并击中相机，嗯，嗯，光感受器，然后有这些，嗯，有点像井，把它想成是小 U
and and photons are coming in from the top and they're hitting this u and because it's kind of a u shape it's sort of trapping the photons almost like a crab uh crab trap or something these photos are getting kind of trapped in this well and and statistically it's just very difficult for them to be able to bounce out. And so then what you can do is you can measure basically how many photons are trapped there. So that's at a really high level, you know, what's kind of going on. So now you have sort of the, I guess, it's probably even more raw than the raw format in the iPhone it was extremely raw just this is like the amount of energy that I've captured by with this photo receptor and then typically what you're going to do is you're going to you know kind of turn that
而且光子从顶部进来，它们击中这个 U，因为它是 U 形的，它有点像捕蟹器或类似的东西，把光子困在这个井里，而且从统计学上讲，它们很难反弹出来。所以你可以做的是，你可以测量基本上有多少光子被困在那里。所以这是在一个非常高的层面上，你知道，正在发生什么。所以现在你有那种，我想，它可能比 iPhone 中的原始格式更原始，这极其原始，这就像我用这个光感受器捕获的能量量，然后通常你会做的是，你会，你知道，有点把它
into you know a more simple kind of integer you know discretized. So you're going to, you know, take these, you know, quantities of energy, this 2D field of energy, and you're going to say, okay, this spot right here is relatively really bright, or you maybe have some absolute point of reference. You say, okay, I want that to be, you know, 1.0, or let's so say 255 if you're doing You know 8-bit and then say okay this point right here. There's very little energy So it's gonna be my zero everything else gonna be somewhere in between and boom now. I have some image That's so now so now that's that's sort of the raw image But there's you know a lot of regularity in that I mean mean, there might be, let's say, a wall, which is completely white.
变成，你知道，一种更简单的整数，你知道，离散化。所以你会，你知道，取这些，你知道，能量量，这个 2D 能量场，你会说，好的，这个点相对来说真的很亮，或者你可能有一些绝对的参考点。你说，好的，我希望那是，你知道，1.0，或者让我们说 255，如果你在做，你知道，8 位，然后说，好的，这个点在这里。能量很少，所以它将是我的零，其他一切都将在两者之间，砰，现在。我有一些图像，所以现在，这就是那种原始图像，但有，你知道，其中有很多规律性，我的意思是，可能有一个墙，它是完全白色的。
So if we have to store 255, 255, 255, 255 next to each other, that's going to take up a lot of space, but there's not really a lot of information there. I mean, imagine having a huge file on your computer that's just all zeros because you haven't filled any of it in yet I mean it's kind of a waste so there's a whole bunch of different compression techniques they take into account you know it could be some of them are you know draw inspiration from the way files are compressed and things like that but they also you take into account the fact that your eye you know is limited in how much it can perceive
所以如果我们必须存储 255, 255, 255, 255 彼此相邻，那将占用很多空间，但那里并没有太多的信息。我的意思是，想象一下在你的电脑上有一个巨大的文件，它全是零，因为你还没有填入任何东西，我的意思是，这有点浪费，所以有各种各样的压缩技术，它们考虑到，你知道，它可能是其中一些是，你知道，从文件压缩的方式中汲取灵感，以此类推，但它们也考虑到这样一个事实，即你的眼睛，你知道，在感知多少方面是有限的
and what sort of irregularities are really important. And so they'll actually use understanding of the human eye and the human brain to make compression very specific for images. That won't keep all of the values exactly intact, but will keep most of them and we'll make the images way, way, way smaller. And you can imagine doing something rather similar for video. So that's basically the high level of what's going on in image processing. So do you want to jump into how to actually process these images?
以及什么样的不规则性真的很重要。所以它们实际上会利用对人眼和人脑的理解来使压缩对图像非常具体。那不会保持所有值完全完整，但会保持大部分，并且会使图像变得非常非常小。你可以想象对视频做类似的事情。所以这基本上是图像处理中正在发生的事情的高层概述。所以你想跳进如何实际处理这些图像吗？
Yeah. So I think we're going to go kind of fast because I think this is a broad range of topic. We might come back and revisit some of these. Yeah, if people are interested, let us know. If there's something that you want more depth on, just shoot us an email or ping us on Discord or something. Yeah, I'm pretty sure Jason just glossed over several textbooks worth of... Yeah.
是的。所以我认为我们会走得有点快，因为我认为这是一个广泛的主题。我们可能会回来重新审视其中一些。是的，如果人们感兴趣，让我们知道。如果有你想要更深入了解的东西，只需给我们发电子邮件或在 Discord 上 ping 我们之类的。是的，我很确定杰森刚刚略过了几本教科书的价值……是的。
So once you have you know some in some digital form you have the data that's been captured from your your photo sensor or you have a file that's been stored and you've recovered it you've loaded it back up again um you get into this sort of world of image processing there we were talking about you know at the in my tool of the show we were talking about sort of raw image versus already having it in eight bits what is that process i mean all that is part of image processing how do you do white balance so it turns out you know our eyes see white that if you measure it in a sort of strictly photon color energy sense is not white the same white in every case um and so but cameras are more sensitive to that and so they'll have a tint where certain scenes will be green or yellow um and how would you adjust it to make it look like i was sort of
所以一旦你有了，你知道，某种数字形式，你有了从你的照片传感器捕获的数据，或者你有一个已经存储的文件，你已经恢复了它，你已经重新加载了它，嗯，你进入了这个图像处理的世界，我们在那里谈论，你知道，在我的节目工具中，我们谈论了原始图像与已经处于 8 位，那是什么过程，我的意思是，所有这些都是图像处理的一部分，你如何做白平衡，所以事实证明，你知道，我们的眼睛看到的白色，如果你以一种严格的光子颜色能量感来测量它，在每种情况下都不是白色，同样的白色，对吧，而且，所以但相机对那个更敏感，所以它们会有一个色调，其中某些场景会是绿色或黄色，以及你将如何调整它以使其看起来像我那种
expressing before um one of the things is like you want it to look like the person thinks it looked like so if you just showed hey here's the scientifically measured thing the camera gave people are gonna go oh there's a really crappy picture like why is my picture outside you know really red well there was a lot of ir content from the sun people are going to be upset right and be like well but it wasn't red and so there's all these techniques for like Jason was pointing out, just like with compression for even just other things where you want to adjust how a picture aesthetically looks so that it's what people sort of perceive, not just what is scientifically measured. And so image processing, we're going to talk about other things, but in part is about understanding how to reconcile the real world to the what you call that. Is that physiology? The sort of like how human brains perceive things um yeah yeah totally and so that's one thing another thing and and all these things intertwine and use each other but at a high level you get this sort of where you want to do filtering on an image so people will talk about
在表达之前，其中一件事是，你希望它看起来像人们认为它应该看起来的样子。所以如果你只是展示相机科学测量出的东西，人们会说，哦，这是一张很烂的照片，为什么我的照片在室外看起来这么红？嗯，因为太阳光里有很多红外线成分。人们会感到不满，说，但这看起来并不红。所以，正如Jason指出的那样，就像压缩技术一样，有很多技巧可以让你调整图片的审美效果，使其符合人们的感知，而不仅仅是科学测量出的结果。因此，图像处理——我们稍后会谈到其他方面——在某种程度上是关于理解如何将现实世界与你所说的……这是生理学吗？即人类大脑感知事物的方式。嗯，是的，完全正确。这是其一，还有另一件事，所有这些事物都是相互交织、相互利用的，但从宏观层面来看，你希望对图像进行某种过滤，所以人们会谈论
i need to sharpen an image or um you can give me things like, I wanna find all the edges in the image. So Jason talked about for compression. Maybe you wanna say, hey, I wanna preserve the edges, but in areas where there's no edges, maybe I just like make it all a single color. Not a great idea, but an idea. And so you wanna find, you know, edges in an image, or you wanna, what if you wanted to blur the background
我需要锐化图像，或者你可以给我一些指令，比如，我想找出图像中的所有边缘。Jason刚才谈到了压缩。也许你想说，嘿，我想保留边缘，但在没有边缘的区域，也许我只想让它变成单一颜色。这不是个好主意，但也是个想法。所以你想找出图像中的边缘，或者你想，如果你想模糊背景该怎么办
of an image, but not the foreground? These are common operations people sort of think about doing and some of them have higher level goals of why you would do those filtering techniques but there's a couple ways of sort of accomplishing them one of them is applying you could call them sort of kernels they're sort of like a set of values where you want to kind of do an element wise multiplication and then sum it up and a little hard to explain, I guess, with words over a podcast and not spend a ton of time. But roughly you're taking at each physical location on the sensor, you have the values that were recorded there after some processing and you want to go
而不是前景？这些是人们通常会考虑的常见操作，其中一些有更高级的目标，说明为什么要使用这些过滤技术，但有几种方法可以实现它们。其中一种是应用所谓的核（kernels），它们是一组数值，你想对它们进行逐元素乘法，然后求和。我想在播客中用语言解释这一点有点难，而且不能花太多时间。但大致上，你在传感器上的每个物理位置，都有经过一些处理后记录在那里的数值，你想去
through each of those locations but as you move if you think about sort of moving along the row moving through columns in a row you're sort of moving left to right in the image which is a representation of left and right in the real world when you move down columns then you're moving down in the real world right you're you're sort of moving in the same spatial sense as the picture itself was and so for instance if i blurred the first 50 percent of rows but not the last 50 percent of rows the top of the scene would be blurred but the bottom wouldn't be um doing those kinds of processing are things that take place in the spatial domain and there's a whole slew of various
遍历每一个位置。但当你移动时，如果你考虑沿着行移动，穿过行中的列，你实际上是在图像中从左向右移动，这代表了现实世界中的左右。当你向下移动列时，你就是在现实世界中向下移动，对吧？你是在以与图片本身相同的空间感移动。因此，例如，如果我模糊了前50%的行，而不是后50%的行，场景的顶部会被模糊，而底部则不会。进行这类处理是在空间域中进行的，还有一大堆各种各样的
techniques for doing things uh like we're talking about sort of like edges exist in the in the spatial they're like you know you can sort of say hey if i have that something was all one color and then it changed to another color that's an edge and i could sort of you know try to detect that spatially but that's not the only way of doing things and in fact when you get to some of these images and cameras like on the the phones now can be you know many megapixels 10 megapixels i don't actually know what the current phones are yeah it's about 10 at least yeah but then high-end slrs can get much higher and scientific application images could get even much much bigger um and so as the megapixel count goes, well, just as the pixel count goes up, every time you're moving in this sort of spatial sense,
处理技术。就像我们谈到的，边缘存在于空间中，你可以说，嘿，如果我有一些东西全是同一种颜色，然后它变成了另一种颜色，那就是一个边缘，我可以尝试在空间上检测它。但这并不是唯一的方法。事实上，当你处理现在的手机摄像头拍摄的图像时，它们可能有千万像素，1000万像素——我其实不知道现在的手机是多少像素，嗯，至少是1000万左右——但高端单反相机可以达到更高，科学应用图像甚至可以更大。因此，随着像素数量的增加，每当你以这种空间方式移动时，
you're slowing further and further down. And so you get a lot of GPU involvement in doing this processing. But sometimes you wanna do hacks by not moving through every pixel location. And one of the things you can do is switch to the frequency domain and we've talked in the past about the foyer transform and roughly how that works i believe we have but once you
你的速度就会越来越慢。所以你会大量使用GPU来完成这种处理。但有时你想通过不遍历每个像素位置来走捷径。你可以做的一件事是切换到频域。我们过去谈论过傅里叶变换以及它的大致工作原理，我相信我们谈过，但一旦你
convert from the spatial domain into the frequency domain there's a whole different i don't want to say language isn't the right word but a whole different technique for how to apply the filters so now we talk about things like if i removed all of jason was talking about before if you have an area that's relatively uniform you could just sort of like you know make that all a single color well what he's saying is if you sort of reinterpret it he said an area with you know sort of a homogenousness to it like a sort of consistency that would be a lot of low frequency information, the information isn't changing very rapidly in that area, versus an area like I talked
从空间域转换到频域，就有一套完全不同的——我不想说语言不是正确的词，而是一套完全不同的技术来应用滤波器。所以现在我们谈论的是，如果我移除了所有——Jason之前谈到的，如果你有一个相对均匀的区域，你可以把它变成单一颜色。嗯，他所说的是，如果你重新解读它，他说一个具有同质性的区域，即某种一致性，那将包含大量低频信息，该区域的信息变化并不剧烈，而像我谈到的
about with edge detection, those are areas with high frequency content, the something is changing very rapidly in that area. So I guess they're a duality there. And so sometimes things are easier to do in the frequency domain so if I go into an image and I sort of did a high pass filter that is I removed a lot of the low frequency content and just you know set those frequencies to zero you at certain frequencies probably wouldn't even really notice that but it's less information I would need to store and so I would achieve some form of compression image compression by reducing the amount I needed to store. But then also I would cause if we sort of revisit, if we go back from the frequency domain into the spatial domain,
边缘检测的区域，那些是包含高频内容的区域，即该区域的某些东西变化非常剧烈。所以我想它们之间存在一种对偶性。有时在频域中处理事情更容易。所以如果我进入一张图像并进行高通滤波，也就是说我移除了大量低频内容，并将这些频率设为零，在某些频率下你可能甚至不会注意到，但我需要存储的信息变少了，所以我通过减少需要存储的数据量实现了一种形式的压缩——图像压缩。但随后，如果我们回顾一下，如果我们从频域回到空间域，
which is what I would show on my computer screen after doing that high pass filter, what you would notice is the image would look different in this case areas with low slow changing values would sort of smooth out and just become become consistent you could also do the reverse you could do a low pass filter and get rid of high frequency contact and that roughly kind of works as like a blur where you know things get averaged out over an area because the frequencies are not the the values aren't able to change very quickly. They can only change over long distances. Um, yeah, I think the one thing about the frequency domain, that's, that's, you know, that's kind of hard to grasp and I'll try to explain it over the, the, over audio as best as I can. But, you know, it's really hard
也就是我在进行高通滤波后在电脑屏幕上看到的结果，你会注意到图像看起来不同了。在这种情况下，数值变化缓慢的区域会变得平滑并变得一致。你也可以做相反的操作，进行低通滤波并去除高频内容，这大致相当于模糊处理，因为频率较低，数值无法快速变化，它们只能在长距离内发生变化。嗯，是的，我认为关于频域的一点是，这有点难以理解，我会尽量通过音频来解释。但是，你知道，这真的很难
to understand, like, what does, what do you sort of get when you convert to the frequency domain? And so I can talk about, like, let's say, like a cosine transform. So, you know, let's say you have an image. So what is that at the end of the day? Let's just take a black and white image or a grayscale image. So you have basically a lattice or a field of numbers and so in the top right you have let's say 255 and that means that in that area of the picture there was something really bright and so you can imagine looking at at some picture and and seeing and breaking that picture down into pixels and each pixel having some brightness so that seems pretty intuitive, right?
去理解，当你转换到频域时，你到底得到了什么？所以我可以谈谈，比如余弦变换。所以，假设你有一张图像。归根结底那是什么？让我们只取一张黑白图像或灰度图像。你基本上拥有一个数字阵列或场，在右上角你有255，这意味着在图片的那个区域有一些非常明亮的东西。所以你可以想象看着一张图片，把它分解成像素，每个像素都有一定的亮度，这看起来很直观，对吧？
But then what's happening with the frequency domain, you still have an image. So you still have a field of pixels, but those pixels aren't arranged spatially and they don't really represent the same thing, right? So you have this whole sort of geometry of this photo. Right. But you could have a 2D field of anything. So in other words, let's say you watch television and there's different channels on the remote.
但频域发生了什么？你仍然有一张图像。所以你仍然有一个像素场，但这些像素不是按空间排列的，它们并不代表同样的东西，对吧？所以你有这张照片的整个几何结构。没错。但你可以拥有任何东西的二维场。换句话说，假设你看电视，遥控器上有不同的频道。
So there's channel one, channel two, channel three. And let's say you were to just put a number based on how much you enjoy that channel. OK, so you really love channel 24 and you really love channel 32 and 58. Right. So you can imagine just having this array and having just a set of numbers there. And you can imagine even if it's kind of a weird thing to think about. But if well, there are some there's some TVs that have sort of almost like I guess two dimensions of channels in a sense so you can have like a channel two and then a 2-2 and so now you have this sort of this sort of also this lattice or
有频道1、频道2、频道3。假设你根据你对该频道的喜爱程度给它打分。好的，你非常喜欢频道24，非常喜欢频道32和58。没错。所以你可以想象拥有这个数组，并在那里设置一组数字。你甚至可以想象，尽管这有点奇怪，但有些电视确实有某种类似二维频道的概念，所以你可以有频道2，然后是2-2，现在你有了这种阵列或
this field where you have channel 1 2 3 4 and then going down that's going across and then going down you have channel you know 1-1 12, 1-3, 1-4, almost like an Excel spreadsheet of channels. And at each one, you have some number for how much you like the channel. So pretty much anything can be represented in, let's say, a spreadsheet or matrix or lattice, right? So what's going on with the frequency domain is at every single location what you have is a specific description of wave, right? Because you can describe a wave by the sort of, what is it, the amplitude and the wavelength, right? So
这个场，你有频道1、2、3、4，然后横向排列，向下排列你有频道1-1、1-2、1-3、1-4，就像一个频道的Excel电子表格。在每一个位置，你都有一个代表你对该频道喜爱程度的数字。所以几乎任何东西都可以用电子表格、矩阵或阵列来表示，对吧？那么频域中发生了什么呢？在每一个位置，你都有一个波的具体描述，对吧？因为你可以通过振幅和波长来描述一个波，对吧？所以
you have these two numbers that you can vary. And as you pick different amplitudes and wavelengths, you get different waves, right? And so at every point in this lattice or in this Excel spreadsheet or whatever analogy you want to use, at every point there is one of these waves, right? And so then the question is, okay, you know, how important is this one wave in this image? So if I take all of these waves and I give them different strengths and then I add them all together, I'll actually reconstruct that original image, right? But at any given pixel, every pixel is representing the strength of an entire wave that's making its way from left to right across the whole image.
你有这两个可以变化的数字。当你选择不同的振幅和波长时，你就会得到不同的波，对吧？在这个阵列或Excel电子表格或任何你想用的类比中，每一个点都有一个这样的波，对吧？那么问题就是，好吧，这个波在图像中有多重要？如果我取所有这些波，给它们不同的强度，然后把它们加在一起，我实际上就能重建原始图像，对吧？但在任何给定的像素处，每个像素都代表了一个正在从图像左侧向右侧传播的完整波的强度。
And so that's something that's kind of really hard to understand, but it's really foundational because when you realize that now every pixel has an entire row's worth of information, that's the jumping point from which you can now do some really, really clever things, like operate on a whole row just by changing a pixel. I think that was a pretty decent pass at doing that without illustrations. I tried my best.
所以这有点难以理解，但它非常基础，因为当你意识到现在每个像素都包含了一整行的信息时，这就是你可以进行一些非常非常巧妙的操作的跳板，比如只需改变一个像素就能对整行进行操作。我想在没有插图的情况下，我已经尽力解释得很清楚了。
So just trying to speed it up a little so we don't get this too long. That's kind of various approaches to filtering. You also get roughly things which I just kind of called computer vision, which is not just filtering or aesthetic improvements, but you might use some of those filtering things to perform image classification or recognition. I think a lot of people think about this as the what you might call like the stereotypical image processing case, like, how does a computer know a picture of a cat is a cat? Yeah, that's crazy hard. And there's many, many different ways of doing it, whether you're recognizing something you've seen before, or recognizing other things. There's also tracking. So I have some object in an image, and I maybe I don't know exactly what it is but I want to track how it moves over time is another task that becomes using a lot of these
所以为了加快速度，我们不要让它太长。这些是各种过滤方法。你还会得到大致上我称之为计算机视觉的东西，它不仅仅是过滤或审美改进，你可能会使用其中一些过滤技术来执行图像分类或识别。我认为很多人认为这是所谓的典型图像处理案例，比如，计算机怎么知道猫的照片是猫？是的，这非常难。有许多许多不同的方法可以做到这一点，无论你是识别你以前见过的东西，还是识别其他东西。还有跟踪。所以图像中有一个物体，我可能不知道它到底是什么，但我想跟踪它随时间如何移动，这是另一个任务，它使用了大量这些
techniques of filtering and you know cropping down the image and looking for changes over time something that you can do another broad class that I'll say here, maybe not the best word for it, but the word that came to mind for me was, oh man, I'm not even going to probably say it correctly, but it's photogrammetry, which is... Photogrammetry? Yeah. So what I was trying to say, so this word, which I had seen written, but I don't think I've ever heard anyone in real life use this word, is like using photos to measure things. So, you know, in the classic crime scene photo, you have like they lay down the ruler next to the shell casing or the puddle of blood and then they take a picture of it. So later they can, you know, compare the lengths on the ruler to how big the puddle was or how big the shoe print was and so just
过滤技术，你知道，裁剪图像并寻找随时间的变化。这是你可以做的另一大类，我在这里说，也许不是最好的词，但我脑海中浮现的词是，哦天哪，我可能甚至说不准，但它是摄影测量（photogrammetry），也就是……摄影测量？是的。所以我试图说的是，这个词，我见过书面形式，但我不认为我在现实生活中听到过任何人使用这个词，它就像是使用照片来测量事物。所以，在经典的犯罪现场照片中，他们在弹壳或血迹旁边放一把尺子，然后拍一张照片。这样以后他们就可以比较尺子上的长度与血迹或鞋印的大小，所以只是
making measurements off of photos but what i meant by this is a probably butchering of the use but a lot of things where you get you know i have uh i strap a camera to the front of my bicycle and then i take a picture i you know one second later take another picture and if i compare those two pictures i can see things that have moved um and then i can begin to understand the shape of the world around me and that that's called sort of structure from motion um with a single camera you put two cameras next to each other and then you can begin to try to reconstruct depth so when you have two cameras next to each other just like your two eyes you get an effect called parallax and based on how much something is experiencing parallax you have an estimate for how close it is
从照片中进行测量。但我指的是，这可能用词不当，但很多情况下，比如我把相机绑在自行车前面，然后拍一张照片，一秒钟后再拍一张照片，如果我比较这两张照片，我可以看到移动的东西，然后我就可以开始理解周围世界的形状。这被称为运动恢复结构（structure from motion）。用一个摄像头，你把两个摄像头放在一起，然后你就可以开始尝试重建深度。所以当你把两个摄像头放在一起时，就像你的两只眼睛一样，你会得到一种叫做视差（parallax）的效果，根据物体经历视差的程度，你可以估计它有多近
so things closer to you have more parallax you can try it hold your finger close close one eye close the other eye it moves a lot hold it further out moves less stars in the night sky don't move at all when you close one eye or another eye um And so measuring this parallax, you can get an estimate of how far things are from you in the world. That's a very interesting thing. You'll see these projects where people do automatic stitching of camera photos where I take a picture
所以离你越近的东西视差越大。你可以试一下，把手指靠近，闭上一只眼，再闭上另一只眼，它移动了很多；把它拿远一点，移动得就少了。夜空中的星星当你闭上一只眼或另一只眼时根本不会移动。因此，测量这种视差，你可以估计世界上的物体离你有多远。这是一件非常有趣的事情。你会看到人们进行相机照片自动拼接的项目，我拍一张照片
and then I move my camera a little and take another picture and later they can sort of stitch it together and make a panorama. To me, that's not exactly photogrammetry, but it kind of falls in sort of the same thing where you're trying to not identify what something is, but identify features in an image and then try to track those features over time or match those features for sort of building up higher level understanding, um, from lower level, uh,
然后我移动相机一点，再拍一张照片，以后他们可以把它们拼接在一起，做成全景图。对我来说，这不完全是摄影测量，但它属于同一类，你不是在识别某物是什么，而是在识别图像中的特征，然后尝试随时间跟踪这些特征，或者匹配这些特征，以便从低级特征构建更高级的理解。
features. Yeah, totally. I mean, there's just an unbelievable amount of depth that we could go into here, but it would take just hours and hours and hours. I do think that there's a lot of super interesting topics, a variety of different methods for doing object detection, object recognition, tracking. We can't cover all of them. If there's something in particular
是的，完全正确。我的意思是，我们可以在这里深入探讨的内容多得令人难以置信，但这需要花费数小时又数小时。我确实认为有很多超级有趣的主题，各种不同的物体检测、物体识别、跟踪方法。我们无法涵盖所有这些。如果有什么特别的东西
that people are interested in you know we'd be more than happy to cover it we've both done a decent amount of image processing in our career so um you know it would be it would be definitely something that we'd be happy to revisit but uh yeah hopefully this gives people an overview of kind of you know the tips and tricks and what's really happening when you you know snap the photo on that um yeah like jason said i mean i think we could take this any number of things i actually think we probably will like i know jason you have a lot of experience with sort of the machine learning aspects and probably talk a little bit to how machine learning and image processing come in to interact with each other yeah Yeah, totally. We could do like a part two.
是人们感兴趣的，你知道，我们非常乐意涵盖它。我们俩在职业生涯中都做过相当多的图像处理，所以，你知道，这绝对是我们乐意重温的话题。但希望这能让大家对当你按下快门时到底发生了什么有一个大致的了解。是的，就像Jason说的，我的意思是，我认为我们可以从任何数量的角度来探讨这个问题。我其实认为我们可能会这样做，我知道Jason你在机器学习方面有很多经验，也许可以谈谈机器学习和图像处理是如何相互作用的。是的，完全正确。我们可以做第二部分。
Yeah, I think that'd be really good. And I do want to mention that the like Swiss army knife of machine vision is OpenCV. So I mean, I think I've, I don't even know how many years now I've used OpenCV at various points, one thing or another, but almost anything you would want to do in computer vision they probably have a function a function or implementation of it in opencv
是的，我认为那会非常好。我确实想提一下，机器视觉的瑞士军刀是OpenCV。所以我的意思是，我甚至不知道我已经使用OpenCV多少年了，在各种不同的点上，但几乎任何你想在计算机视觉中做的事情，他们可能在OpenCV中都有一个函数或实现
for just all sorts of things and so it also involves it also has abilities to show images and open images and it's not the only thing for doing that but it does have many many advanced algorithms as well as a lot of basic algorithms. And that's available, I know, for both Python and C++, and I'm sure has bindings for other languages. Yeah, OpenCV, if you're willing to invest the time, is amazing. I mean, it's got everything. It's insanely fast. They've all these sort of specializations for if the image is floating point, if it's different formats of images,
用于各种各样的事情。它还具有显示图像和打开图像的能力，虽然它不是唯一能做到这一点的工具，但它确实拥有许多许多高级算法以及大量基础算法。我知道它适用于Python和C++，我相信也有其他语言的绑定。是的，OpenCV，如果你愿意投入时间，它是令人惊叹的。我的意思是，它应有尽有。它快得离谱。他们有各种各样的专业化处理，如果图像是浮点型的，如果它是不同格式的图像，
it handles them in the most efficient way possible and all of that. Two things, two libraries that are a little more for beginners. There's Python image library, which is quite good. You can do some basic things like edge detection, dilation, things like that. There's also SciPy ND image, which is really interesting. I don't know why they made this such a focus, but it supports arbitrary dimensional images. So you can have a 27-dimensional image. The only thing I've ever found that useful for is for videos because you can think of a video as a cube where it's just a set of images that are kind of stacked up in a third dimension. But if you really are going to be serious about image processing, grabbing a good book on OpenCV or diving into the tutorials is definitely the way to go.
它会以最高效的方式处理它们。还有两个更适合初学者的库。一个是Python图像库（PIL），它相当不错。你可以做一些基本的事情，比如边缘检测、膨胀等。还有一个SciPy ND image，它非常有趣。我不知道为什么他们把它作为重点，但它支持任意维度的图像。所以你可以有一个27维的图像。我发现它唯一有用的地方是视频，因为你可以把视频看作一个立方体，它只是一组在第三维度上堆叠起来的图像。但如果你真的想认真对待图像处理，买一本关于OpenCV的好书或深入研究教程绝对是正确的方法。
That library is fantastic. Just a random bit of trivia. basically productionized at willow garage which is uh um just like a hardware hacking place that shut down uh i guess about four or five years ago but it was pretty famous for doing all sorts of crazy robotics all right well till next time yeah um it's it's been great as i said you know there's been there was a chance to kind of meet with some fans and things like that, which was awesome. Keep writing in, keep giving us your ideas, your show, show ideas and other things. We'd love to hear from you. Our next episode, you know, think about interview episodes. You never, it's never a guarantee.
那个库太棒了。只是一个随机的小知识。它基本上是在Willow Garage产品化的，那是一个硬件黑客场所，大约四五年前关闭了，但它以进行各种疯狂的机器人技术而闻名。好吧，下次见。是的，这很棒。正如我所说，有机会见到一些粉丝等等，这太棒了。继续写信给我们，继续给我们你的想法、节目创意和其他事情。我们很乐意听到你的声音。我们的下一集，你知道，考虑一下采访集。你永远无法保证。
You know, it could always fall through, but fingers crossed. You know, it should be fine. We're gonna have a really cool interview coming up next month really excited to get to it and we'll catch you all then Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution Share Alike 2.0 license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide attribution to Patrick and I and share alike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你知道，它总是可能失败，但祈祷吧。你知道，应该没问题。下个月我们将进行一次非常酷的采访，非常期待，到时候见。Throwdown是在知识共享署名-相同方式共享2.0许可下发布的。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传播作品，进行重混、改编，但你必须注明我和Patrick的署名，并以相同方式共享。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。